the uk's royal navy
sent one of their warships into the
black sea and
it was doing a mission between ukraine
and georgia it traveled along the coast
of crimea which russia is climbing as
its own so russia fired warning shots
and actually began dropping bombs now uk
didn't the uk
denies this they said there was no
warning shots but a journalist for the
bbc said he did hear shots fired
the uk is now claiming those were just
russian drills off in the distance
russia came back and said if you come
again we will bomb you
this time and the uk's response is we do
not recognize your claims over crimea
and we are absolutely going to be
sending more warships along this route
so
we'll see in this game of chicken who
backs down first but russia has actually
said
that in conventional warfare nuclear
retaliation is on the table
and china has even said that they will
join russia in a counter-attack
just for u.s provocations now maybe this
is all
just saber-rattling because certainly
things like this have happened before
but it does
make me worried considering the other
news where the chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff came out
was like well what's wrong with being
woke you know i white rage i got to
understand that it caused the
the riots on january 6 and i'm like oh
geez are we capable of defending
ourselves because it's not just about
international conflict
the fourth turning suggests we're in a
crisis period and very well may be
domestic crisis it could very well be a
great depression or some kind of civil
conflict
and seeing all this news about blackrock
buying opponens
news stories popping up saying
millennials shouldn't buy property
millennials who are already massively in
debt with student loans
now they'll be in debt and they won't
own anything yeah it seems like we are
headed towards very i don't know
dystopian future where
the millennial generation and those
younger will just be i don't know surfs
in some kind of neo-feudalist system
so joining us to talk about the war on
small business we have recovering
investment banker and author carol roth
hey tim how are you doing pretty good
how are you good i'm glad you used the
recovering investment banker instead of
former because it is sort of this
12-step
program and i'm permanently stuck on
step 11.
which which one is panic
well it is kind of creepy what we're
seeing with the the way the fed works
especially when it comes to these these
these houses and the black rock store
that's been popping up the feds
basically just giving them money they
buy it it's it's no risk to them
yet regular working-class people
millennials have no no way to out-bid
free money from one of these massive
firms yeah i mean this is what happens
when you have
central planning and and central banking
gone awry i mean basically the fed
has disrupted risk in the market
they have said if you put your money at
risk you know
you get nothing and so people have to
take on riskier and riskier bets and so
you've got two different things going on
here you've got these big
firms that have tons of capital that
they need to deploy and earn a return on
uh for their investors they're going out
and they're trying to
find investments and they can't find
investments to get those yields so now
they're turning to the housing market
at the same time you've got retirees and
savers and main street
who are just trying to earn a return on
the small amount of money that they have
also trying to to chase yield and
basically they're saying well if you put
it in the bank
we're just going to give you almost
nothing for it and then we're going to
turn around and lend it to blackrock so
that they can go
buy these houses and it's basically free
money for blackrock and it
is a selling out of main street to wall
street
this is all part of the biggest transfer
of wealth in the history
of the world throughout the pandemic and
you wrote a book about it so we'll we'll
definitely talk about that right on we
got to
we got ian hello tim hi hi uh hello
carol
i'm interested to find out what what
your what your motive was to get out of
the banking industry this is really
interesting so i'm glad you're here
and i am here in the corner as well i
love all of my lady guests each one of
them is kind of a role model for me in
different ways so i'm really excited
about tonight's conversation
and knowledgeable and not to like you
know self-identify here but i'm often
known as like a dude in a dress
so you know like i'll i'll claim the
ladies but
i'll claim whatever as well yeah well
before we get started head over to
timcast.com and become a member we're
going to have a bonus podcast episode
coming up around 11 p.m
we do this so there's a lot of things we
can't say on youtube so we have to
choose our battles
instead of just saying you know we'll
we'll shut down the youtube and we'll
never speak again because we say one
wrong thing you do back
axes us we are trying to build out
timcast.com to do more than just be a
youtube channel we got to do this
we got to build culture we have to bring
on awesome journalists so we have
cassandra fairbanks who's incredible and
she's writing articles for us now
we have a few more journalists that are
on their way to join the team and we
actually hired
an unsolved mysteries writer get this
i don't know if i should say this i'm
gonna say it anyway we're actually now
in the very preliminary stage of
looking into lost confederate gold in
the south
wow i got an email from someone and they
were like we believe we
know where this lost confederate gold is
hidden but they've never had the
resources i guess to actually it's a
protected area so you can't dig so they
need like very expensive equipment and i
was like at the very least
we'll investigate the story of the lost
confederate gold this isn't going to be
like el capone's tomb is this
because i'm from chicago so you remember
when geraldo rivera did like
the 20-hour special and then they opened
it up and there was nothing in there
very well maybe the the goal for this
kind of
content that we're producing is not
necessarily to be
groundbreaking news and historical
documentation but
literally to tell the story of what
happened with his confederate gold white
went missing why people think it's there
and then who knows maybe we'll find it
or something and then a museum will get
it i have no i really don't think so
is geraldo going to be hosting no no
i i've met ralph a couple times you know
he's all right but i'm not the biggest
fan
you know did he get punched in the face
in the 80s or something
he also said like those like half naked
selfies like around
twitter and stuff yeah i like them
anyway
we had a lot of stuff going on we got a
lot of stuff done so we've got obviously
the vlog
um we um we're going to be ramping up
production on that and that's just going
to be fun silly uh culture building
so uh we're gonna be doing this podcast
on paranormal mysteries and i think we
actually have put together the team to
start producing it so it's gonna be
really amazing it's gonna be like
feature episodes with
sound effects and creepy noises and
stuff and uh yeah someone emailed me
saying i think i know where the lost
confederate gold is and i was like oh
hey should we write about this this
sounds really fascinating
and so we'll definitely do that so go to
timcast.com because aside from that we
are going to have on the ground
reporters which is the next
phase it's it's it's it's not as easy as
it sounds just hire someone
to go go out and do this stuff but um
it's not that hard we've got to find the
right people
people we trust who will do a good job
so we'll be doing that as well so again
teamcast.com
that bonus episode be up around 11.
let's read this first story
we're going to talk about this here war
from
nine news australia uk plans to sail
through crimean waters
again as russia threatens to bomb on
target
now this is all basically because russia
sees crimea and i'll try and very very
simplify everything for those aren't
familiar with the full story
ukraine seems to be going the way of
nato this was several years ago
and that meant russia was going to lose
its only warm water port in the black
sea which is crimea
so they moved in and claimed the people
of crimea voted to join russia
well apparently the people of ukraine
don't believe that's the case and
i know a lot of people in ukraine and i
know people who have family and friends
and criminals say it's also not the case
they want to join russia
there's not much you can do when you're
being occupied by a military and they
have
no way to defend themselves well now you
have the uk who doesn't recognize this
running along the coastline and russia
is basically dropping bombs and firing
warning shots and threatening
we will bomb you if this is the case so
let me just read a little bit they say
russia annexed crimea from ukraine after
a military intervention in the region in
2014.
russia said the uk's hms defender went
three kilometers inside what described
as its territory off of cape what does
it say violent in crimea
just before noon on wednesday a nation's
territorial waters extend 12 nautical
miles
off from its coastline any foreign
warship going past that limit
would need permission of the country to
do so with a few exceptions
prime minister boris johnson and defense
secretary ben wallace both backed the
assertion we don't recognize the russian
annexation of crimea it was illegal
these are ukrainian waters and it was
entirely right
to use them to go from a to b he denied
that uk russian relations write historic
low
noting that i can remember times in my
own lifetime when things have been far
worse the important point is that we
don't recognize the russian annexation
of crimea
this part of sovereign this is part of
sovereign ukrainian territory
mr johnson told reporters on thursday
during a visit to an army barracks in
england
this is a game of chicken you know who
do you think's got the the
the cajones to make that move well
speaking of the cajones like
where did the uk get the car right from
like
like the fact that they're like of all
the things that they have going on
in the uk with brexit and and trying to
sort out their economy
like where are they like peak hocking
around like how did they come to the
table with this
actually it's kind of a sad thing to
think about because i did this threat on
the founding fathers
uh earlier how i was like that this the
people who signed the declaration of
independence
knew that they were declaring war on the
most powerful military the world had
ever seen
and they thought they were going to lose
many many did and it was some say it was
only because of french intervention that
we actually were able to win
the french of course had an interest in
defeating the british uh it's funny that
that narrative of the british being so
powerful
and now it's like wow where did britain
get the balls to go up against russia
oh man that's it but what but seriously
like like what do they get out of this
ukrainian situation and why are they i
mean
they know they don't have a strong ally
in the us anymore in terms of being able
to support so like why are they out
there
like we're gonna be you know going up
against russia and russia's like we must
break you
how how did that sort of all i don't
know you know it's interesting because
the the big narrative for a long time
was that
ukraine was had there's a natural gas
monopoly through the gazprom
you know company russia and it's running
through ukraine so the us wanted the
qatar turkey pipeline to go up through
syria and turkey and then into
the you know into um the eu to offset
their monopoly and lower prices
but syria said no and then war breaks
out it's all chaos and conflict and then
joe biden's like
i'm going to improve this uh was it
nordstrom 2
where they're building another pipeline
and biden's like we're going to allow
this
so it's really confusing to me when
you're trying to follow through this
this history
and the news about why we're currently
entering this level of conflict
i mean obviously we are allies with the
uk and this is a lot a lot about
nato but why allow russia to build
another pipeline
through you know uh it's it's like just
north of europe along the along the
coast
why allow that but then taunt them and
play these games
and be upset about ukraine it seems
something's broken right now we're
trying to
frame it as if we did nothing wrong and
we were we got attacked so we're the
ones
that are they're just in the situation
because
i mean but the the truth is it's moronic
to poke the beast regardless i
i don't know man history will tell you
know and i'm a money person so i'm like
trying to follow the pipeline and follow
the money and going okay like who's
benefiting where
and where are the dollars flowing
because at the end of the day
that's on one side or the other that's
what this has got to be all about either
it's about somebody getting money or
someone trying to bleed more money out
of the us
i think i think the interest in this the
story may just be
saber rattling there have been like
russian flybys before
there have been like russia you know
their planes entering like u.s airspace
kim jong-un got to too much uh too much
journalistic space for all of his little
things so they had to kind of step up
and go no we're bad guys too don't
forget about us but these things happen
and usually like we don't see much so
i'm wondering if it's
people are interested in this simply
because of the idea of like the fourth
turning i mean i'll say this is one of
the reasons i'm interested in in seeing
this news because it sounds like
the uk and russia are playing a game of
chicken and of course if that comes to
blows
we're involved um there's a fear that
we're in this crisis period where
there's going to be a major
war china of course is saying we'll work
with russia to counter attack
so you know i i can't remember was it
bannon who was talking about this
they were saying that you know russia
should not be aligned with china but
we've effectively
forced that on them especially when the
democratic party has been repeatedly
just bash russia
bashing non-stop so russia's you know
pushed back saying okay fine it's us
against you
now they work with china but again this
could just be
words it could be meaningless russia
could just be shaking their fist from
the shoreline while the uk passes by and
nothing ever happens but it's a great is
a great way to put the
us in a financial and a national pickle
isn't it
especially when you don't have sort of
strength um at the top
leadership because what is it that we
can't afford more than
anything else it's certainly another war
and so from a dollar standpoint as well
from a national standpoint
um the split in terms of people who
would be foreign against that
you know we don't need that right now
and certainly if you're savvy if you're
in in russia and you're in china
you're aware that we don't need that
right now there's also
wokeness right this whole critical race
theory battle and its subsets
tearing at the core of the united states
and now we see
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff just being like outright like
what's wrong with being woke i take
offense to that i want to understand
white rage and it's like oh geez
i can only imagine that russia and china
are well aware of the rift in the us
and this is what worries me if the uk
gets bold and says we're going to drive
our boats by
russia might be like hey if we bomb them
right now they can't do anything about
it the u.s is fractured
their military's gone woke so is that i
don't know what do you think
is that is that a big risk or am i
overthinking things no i think it's a
it's a huge risk and i think we need to
be talking to our little friends in
britain and telling them to settle down
a little bit
because like you said it's sort of moral
hazard right they're the ones who are
gonna
to poke the beast as you said but they
aren't the ones that are gonna suffer
most of the repercussions it's gonna
fall back on us so
you know maybe they might just want to
slow their role a little bit
that scares me though because you know
we saw china saying that the u.s is not
in a position of strength
if the reality is we do have to be like
uk please don't
don't bother crimea we know russia stole
it but
we can't do it now that was not a good
time maybe come back to us in a couple
years
man i feel like i feel like the u.s is
in trouble the whole
the whole world is in trouble it's a
house of cards yeah if there's a global
war it's i mean that's
could set us back 10 000 years i mean we
did did you see what china was saying
about kovid
and lab leak they were like if you
investigate the origins
we need it was china state media
speaking to themselves saying we need to
up
production of nuclear weapons to send a
shiver down the spines of the american
elites
so you got like nuclear sable writing
russia apparently they issued a
statement saying
that their official response to any war
including conventional warfare like if
some missiles go flying they'll launch
nukes
now will they really i don't think so
they're like we'll respond to aggression
but we will use
nukes i think a lot of this could just
be like fist shaking from the shoreline
you know testing the waters that could
be it too
yeah but maybe the uk warship is just
sailing by and then russia is like
uk and that's all that really happens
you know yeah
i wonder if there's a crypto tie in here
as we we've
kind of offline talked about you know
china's role in
crypto and digital currency and
obviously they're trying to become
the world's reserve currency and what a
better way to
you know continue the the great work
that the federal reserve has done in
devaluing the dollar
then trying to bring us into another war
that we need to print a bunch of money
for that we can't afford
you know not to like throw out random
conspiracy theories here but just again
trying to kind of connect
things that potentially could happen
there could be a tie-in with that
well i think i think it all is there's i
mean first of all we probably don't even
realize how much is connected to all of
this yeah
we might be looking over here at this
you know uk
the hms defender right and we're like
wow what a story
and we might not even know that an
actual
you know conflict with actual live fire
happened somewhere else you know what i
mean like
the news that comes out for instance the
gulf of tonkin incident which brought us
into uh vietnam
we didn't actually know the full details
for decades we just got some reports
later on i just found out the uss
maine was like a false flag that got us
involved in the spanish-american war
to liberate cuba liberate from the
spanish empire it was just blew up
no one knew why and then william
randolph started printing articles that
were like remember the main remember the
main and everyone went to war with cute
with
with uh okay so if we're talking about
like things that are distractions so
then we had all of these cyber attacks
that happened in the us
on the pipeline on the meat plants and
stuff and it's sort of planting the
seeds
oh russia's doing these things russia's
doing these things now we've got this
conflict with russia
so yeah we actually have this we
actually have this story this is a big
story right now um the daily mail
reports national guard is preparing for
a major cyber attack that would bring
down utilities across the us
troops tackle massive simulated breach
during two week training exercise
after hack of colonial pipeline brought
nation's fuel supply to its knees
all right i i think they're taking it
seriously
i'm worried that they're taking it
seriously way too late
but yeah um was this on the list was
this on the list of the
the critical infrastructure that you're
not that our playbook of here's the
things that you should attack
thank you very much that was one of
these stupid i can't believe it what was
it exactly
biden said something to putin right
that's what this is so he gave he gave a
list
of like here are our most critical
infrastructure things here's off limits
here's what you can attack so implicitly
he's saying like it's okay if you attack
other things just don't detect
this and then also he's basically saying
here are our most important things so if
you are a bad nefarious guy
here are the things that you wanted to i
mean just the the strategy behind that
like who's advising on that because we
know it's probably not
coming from joe biden right so who's the
genius who came up
with the list of the infrastructure and
what's that on the list
i can only hope that whoever advised him
says here's the 16 things we really
don't care about
tell him we care about it so that he
goes after that i see four
chests right like small businesses you
could totally take out main street we
don't we don't
care about that no but i i i think the
simple solution
the one that makes the least amount of
assumptions joe biden was like
oh russia better not attack the things
we actually need hey hey putin i'm
warning you don't don't attack these
don't attack these you know what i'm
saying and here's the list it's the
playground it's like the playground
bully it's like okay
okay you can you can beat me up but
don't break my glasses because my mom's
gonna be mad and she's gonna ground me
she'll ground you and you get beat up i
i
i couldn't believe that story right so
it's like they're doing war games now
it's like it's like negative 1d chess
yeah
brilliant it's like it's like you're
playing checkers with somebody
but joe biden's going like come on come
on man i don't know how to move
i don't even know the rules and you're
like joe joe it's like you just move
diagonally it's monopoly you just buy
boardwalk put some houses on it
you know i guess what's what's crazy
about this is
uh daily mail has been saying russia did
all of these hacks
like that's been the median narrative
the whole time so when colonial pipeline
got hit by these hackers
daily mail just kept saying russian hack
on on us russian hack on yes and i'm
like none of that's confirmed even biden
said we don't know for sure
but there were elements of the media
saying it was a russian attack or
russian attributed a russian associated
and and you know what it feels like it's
like we're back on schedule because uh
before donald trump got in office this
was everything that was happening you
know russia annexed crimea
then the the us and and nato and western
allies were getting involved in ukraine
there was
separatist conflict and then trump gets
in and all of a sudden this
fades away well i'll tell you something
else that was interesting
all of the things that were involved
were things that were sort of
progressive agenda items that they
wanted to crack down on so you had a
pipeline which obviously we know that
the
the natural gas issue is out there we
had meat
which was another issue and then it was
you were using
using crypto to pay for this and we know
that the us government's
really uncomfortable so the fact that
all sort of elements of the story all
revolved around
things that the government you know
doesn't really have on their agenda
is sort of an interesting thing for me
as well did you hear that there was gas
there are gas stations out of gas in
colorado this past week or so
so there's there's an interesting story
behind um part of the the disruption
and that's with the government's you
know deciding
winners and losers and sort of
interfering in the economy
there are not enough drivers able to
drive the tanker trucks
and so it's now taking an extra couple
of days to get
the gas to the gas stations and the
people who used to be the tanker truck
drivers
you know they went to work for amazon or
they found other jobs or they're staying
home or whatnot
you can't just pull a random person off
the street and say go
drive a tanker truck right that's a
specialized thing so that's part of this
supply chain disruption that supposedly
nobody
expected we've had a lot of people super
chat us saying that's
not the case that you know they're
people like i'm a trucker there's no
shortage this is not true
now i can't you know verify a super chat
but
i'm i'm i'm i've gotten emails from
people saying they're truckers and it's
not the case
the challenge is if the media says it
and we all
believe it but then people are like hey
i'm a trucker that's not true it's like
who do you trust
do you trust the media i'm like that's
that's a tough call no right right
i can't trust any of it i mean and it's
anecdotal at best if someone's super
chats and they're like hey
it worked i saw it so it's real
everywhere like i saw it here so
everywhere right exactly
it may be in their particular area or
their particular company as well
you mentioned in the previous segment
how there's like maybe a tie-in with
china's move against crypto and stuff
and we we have talked about all of the
moves made during the pandemic
and its potential relationship to a
coming war so a few things i've said is
not to imply a conspiracy i'm not saying
that i'm saying how fortuitous for the
united states
based on what happened so you have
decentralization from major cities
if a city gets nuked well half a million
people leave new york and many of these
people are leaders in industry or
high-ranking individuals in certain
companies
and they're working from home in
different areas so now it's harder to to
take out our economy because you can't
just go after one city you still can't
you kind of can
and then you look at what's going on
with like gas
stations having limited fuel a lot of it
feels
like there's something happening behind
the scenes we don't know about
we don't have a very strong journalistic
apparatus in this country to inform us
about what's going on
and maybe the picture is just too big at
this point for any one organization or
individual to see
but i look at all this and i'm wondering
if like look our critical
infrastructure gets attacked that's oil
pipelines and
it's meat production which was like i
think a fifth of all meat production
then i saw the story about a gas
shortage in colorado and i'm like now
explain to me how that happens
like oh it's a trucker shortage then i
hear from people like bro i'm a trucker
there's no shortage then where's the gas
and who do i trust
well the media has not been you know
faithful or i should say honest to the
american people
i honestly don't know now you look at
what's happening with you know crimea
and the uk
you look at china and taiwan sending 28
planes in the taiwanese defense zone and
i'm like
is it possible that the things we're
seeing with like gas snapping at gas
stations
critic critical infrastructure being
attacked and uh you know just these
these international conflicts that
we are dangerously close to a real
conflict and both the you know the us
as well as russia china are shoring up
the defenses stockpiling preparing or
something like that
i mean i never take anything off the
table i leave all options open i think
that there's um you know some other
central planning issues that are going
on here which we'll definitely get into
but i i wouldn't take that off the table
i mean based on history and based on
what we know about truthfulness
coming out of government central
planning and like you said the the
sort of media or the the corporate press
complicity
in terms of all of this i i wouldn't
take it off the table i think when you
talk about central planning it makes me
think of the swiss bank
bank of international settlements we
mentioned earlier a little bit that it
is like a global central
financial authority that is trying like
using you know these lockheed martin and
these big
arms dealers to like play chess with all
these countries and they're using our
military as
pawns against each other yeah it's
interesting i mean i
tend to be a little bit more domestic
focused and we
certainly have um at least today you
know most of
the wealth in the world and i kind of
feel like the central planners
in our country um like most central
planners
think that they know better than they
actually do i don't know that i
buy the global conspiracy because i feel
like
if you have that central power like why
are you sharing it with these
other guys over there i mean we know
that cartelization never works somebody
always breaks off
and so i feel like like we're we're
probably the leaders
of that so if there's something that's
going on it's probably starting with us
because i mean we've got the financial
center
we've got the the wealth we've got the
innovation
so the idea that there's some other
puppet master in switzerland
not to say that they're not doing things
in europe with the ecb and whatnot but
that they're actually controlling the us
narrative
unless they're just smarter than our
central planners which is i mean
anybody could pick five people out of
the phone book and there's there are
central planners
um you know i don't know it's an
interesting interesting discussion
i'm not a big fan of you know the big
bang conspiracies or anything like that
i certainly think we have a problem with
the fed
yeah we have a big bank conspiracy with
the federal reserve here in the united
states you know you know what's funny is
like
it is a conspiracy isn't it you know the
definition of conspiracy a group of
people doing something
committing some amoral unethical or
criminal act in secret
i mean that was literally the founding
of the fact i actually talk about it in
the book
um the founding of the fed that the idea
that it was decentralized
this cloak of decentralization uh which
i sourced back if you want to read like
deep dive on this it's a book called the
uh the case against the fed by dr murray
rothbard who's a now deceased economist
who's great uh but like
the way that they founded the fed was
completely
to have this uh kind of bait-and-switch
feel on the american public so oh no
we're decentralized we're not part of
the government
but when you think about the fed so i
mean this is really messed up so it's
owned by
it's it's member banks but if it makes a
profit
that goes back to the us treasury not to
its owners it gets its mandate from
congress but congress doesn't have any
ability to know or audit what's actually
going
on so is it part of the government is it
decentralized
the way that it's described is it sort
of a a
big bank government cartel yeah and they
call it federal
give me control of a nation's currency
and i care not who makes its laws
child yeah is that what you have nathan
michelle rothschild
i saw that quote earlier today yeah uh
bavarian was amshell the bavarian banker
i mean he's like the guy that founded
the central bank basically and then he
had three kids i think it was amshah he
had three kids one went to england one
went to france and one went somewhere
else
and it was the one in england that
really created this global banking
influence
yeah which which founding father was who
said that centralized banking is more
powerful than any standing army
jefferson was it jefferson yeah
man those guys were smart weren't they
they understood yeah i mean they warned
against this
and they had tried to do these central
banking structures before
landing on the fed and national banking
structures and they had all failed
and so this was kind of like okay let's
let's rejigger it
and the funny part was that the national
bank that they had put in place that was
put in place by these bankers like the
the morgans and you know these kind of
financiers
they felt like they didn't have enough
control even though they were the ones
who
had structured it and so that's why they
came up with this concept of what the
fed is today
and by the way so it started out with
sort of these nefarious intentions and
has gone completely off the rails since
then
are you familiar with the great reset so
i i'm
like kind of macro level like i haven't
dug into
each of it but certainly on a macro
level you just have this world economic
forum thing about how there's going to
be a global reset of capitalism for
stakeholder capitalism and it's very
woke
and we start seeing these things happen
in the united states with small
businesses a lot of what i think you
cover
that's why i ask because a lot of people
have suggested that the moves the
government was making
whether intentional or not greatly
benefited this this idea of a great
reset
yeah you wrote a book about the war on
small businesses
tell me what the government did and what
happened to these small businesses
throughout the past year yes so we're on
small business so this is
the most underreported infuriating
story of the last 12 to 15 months and
really
if you want to talk about it going back
decades but really in the last 12 to 15
months you had a government deciding
who was essential and who was
non-essential who was going to
thrive and who is going to fight to
survive and this was not
based on data this was not based on
science
this was based on political clout and
connections
and what that did and we talked a little
bit about it is it enabled
the greatest wealth transfer that we've
ever seen in history and the greatest
power transfer
you had seven technology companies in
2020
that gained collectively 3.4 trillion
dollars in value and seven companies
at the same time that you had main
street businesses by june of 2020
hamilton projects that 400 000 of them
had closed permanently
millions more struggling to survive oh
and by the way
it was a record year for initial public
offerings it was a
record year for spax which are special
purpose acquisition companies which are
highly
speculative investment vehicles that
only pop up in very frothy environments
where people are
trying to chase the old and you know
again there's this just
giant disconnect spenders or savers and
retirees you know all getting
thrown under the bus and nobody
wants to talk about this nobody wants to
talk about this battle that's going on
and that has been sort of laid out for
us
over the last couple of decades as we've
moved away from
capitalism to more more towards central
planning
and then the worst part about the whole
thing is that capitalism is the one
that's getting blamed for it
even though it was done by government
mandates and so
that's why uh as as i was approached to
kind of do
an economic debrief of on what was
happening during the pandemic
that the small business story just you
know had that line it was like so
important
but it was also just important in terms
of creating that through line
between decentralization and central
planning because that's what so many of
us
are fighting for if you're if it's not
small business it's crypto
it's the gig economy it's the creator
economy you know all these are trying to
to go you know in a decentralized manner
to to fight back
and have those free market tenants
against this consolidated power
and so it's really important for us to
all be aligned on that i want to ask you
about something that biden said
and uh he said it in a really weird way
but okay
we got the story pay them more bizarre
moment biden
whispers and blames employers low wages
for worker shortages
then insists inflation will only be
temporary so there's two things here
this idea that the reason companies are
struggling to find
people to work for them is that they're
not paying well enough but we also know
that
the cdc just extended the eviction
moratorium which is in essence free
money for a lot of people
there's also the extended unemployment
benefits which is literally free money
for a lot of people not that i'm
suggesting these people don't need that
money
but it certainly creates an economic
pressure where
people are less inclined to work or go
seek out work
and so biden is making the the
accusation that it's the it's a small
business's fault or companies in general
for not paying more
i don't i mean so so basically so this
is this is all part of the plan and i'll
just
ask you to keep this in the back of your
mind as we talk about this
like if you were trying to kill small
businesses
if you were trying to only have a
handful of big businesses and you were
trying to get people more dependent
on the government through ubi those
kinds of things
would you do anything different than
what played out the last
12 to 15 months without being just 100
obvious
um so yeah i mean you have the
government now in competition
with the businesses for employees
and i'm all for paying employees as much
as possible i think
it's a good business practice i think
that you retain better employees and
more loyal
but you don't want to legislate that
because then
you've got 16 year olds who are holding
up a sign that says come see the
sandwich stop who are getting paid 30
an hour when you could just stick that
you know in the side of the road
um there's an economic reason behind it
so
the fact that we have 9.3 million
jobs that we can't fill is because
central planners didn't want you to be
able to fill them and they wanted people
to be conditioned
to depend on the government but we know
that the only people who've ever gotten
wealthy being on the government dollar
are politicians
nobody ever gets wealthy on that on the
government dole it feels to me like this
is all part of the same
exact uh problem
i'll call it a problem right so you had
the the government shuts down in a
variety of fashions different
governments different jurisdictions shut
down small business
walmart target big box stores amazon
they're all open so they made what
was the number was it three trillion so
it wasn't necessary it was there were
seven tech companies so you know
google amazon tesla facebook
whatever it was 3.4 trillion dollars in
value
two tiers to that so like you said they
were open for business so the small
businesses that couldn't be open for
businesses saw their customers moving to
these big companies and
dollars going that way and then you had
the federal reserve pumping in money to
support the stock market so the stock
prices increased
so the value of those companies
increased as well so it was done
on two levels now think about the next
circumstance created by the government
not only are
small businesses competing with the
government because they're paying people
but all of the money i should say for
most of the money last year went to
these big massive box stores
so who can afford to pay more when joe
biden says pay them more okay well
amazon's like you know we did have you
know massive profits last year
all right we'll increase wages that can
out compete the government
but that mom and pop coffee shop they
can't just manifest money out of nowhere
they can't compete and there's no
surprise that you know prior to this you
had saw you'd seen
amazon and some of the other big
companies start pushing
for a higher mandated minimum wage and
the reason why they started pushing for
a higher mandated minimum wage because
they know it's anti-competitive and they
know what would drive some of the
smaller players out of business
and so basically that's what's happening
on a de facto basis here is they're
trying to
end around instead of legislating it
they're trying to do it by
we're going to interfere in the market
we're going to make it really difficult
for people to want to go back to work
we're going to compensate them for
staying home
and then we're going to force these
businesses who are
have been struggling they were shut down
by government mandate they were not
appropriately compensated for giving up
their property
for the public good under eminent domain
concepts under the constitution
then you just get back you've hung on
this whole time
and you can't find anybody to work and
and by the way
it's not even just low wages i've talked
to small businesses all over this
country
they're paying higher wages they're
offering bonuses
many of them can't even get people to
apply
so it's not even just like oh well you
need to raise the wage a couple dollars
because they've done that and they still
can't get people back
some have argued that this the problem
here is fulfillment
you know with with last year people
giving being given the opportunity
not to say flip burgers which i don't
think i don't think there's any lack of
dignity in being a burger flipper people
love burgers
but a lot of people they want more
fulfilling work and so the argument is
they're just choosing to avoid burger
king or mcdonald's or even
working at a coffee shop so so yes and
no so i do think there are a lot of
people who have the opportunity
for ones to pause and reflect and
actually make some decisions which i
think is
if there's any silver lining maybe
that's one of them
but if that were the case we wouldn't
have 9.3 million jobs
unfilled you would have the ones at the
higher levels getting filled and then
these other ones
not being fulfilled and that's not what
the data is coming back and telling us
nobody can find the jobs and it's not
just the burger flipper jobs it's a lot
of
mid-tier and and other jobs as well and
then the
the interesting part if you look at kind
of the data around wages
you're going to see oh well wages really
haven't increased
but the hidden sort of data behind that
is that a lot of boomers took the
opportunity to
to retire and to opt out of the
workforce so you have people who are
making
high five and six um figure salaries who
said you know what i'm gonna retire so
those wages have now come out
and when you're computing the average
obviously that brings the average down
so even at if you look at the low end
those have gone up enormously but if you
look at it as just one
giant pie it looks like oh well wages
haven't moved at all
another another component too is um
these are the jobs we can see
when we when we see burger king putting
up a sign saying 500 sign on bonus or a
thousand dollars right
what people don't realize is that
sourcing raw materials
and even manufacturing jobs a lot of
these a lot of these companies that you
don't
know even exist are struggling to find
people
uh then the inflation pieces you talked
you you had uh right right
let in with so that you have the problem
with not being able to find people which
is making it more
more costly but then trying to get the
raw materials and everything kind of
running through the the supply chain
and then obviously just having just an
enormous amount of money supply out
there all these things driving up prices
so again if you're the small business
you can't find somebody to work and
you've hung out to survive
you also if you're trying to buy chicken
because you make chicken wings
we saw you know was it buffalo wild
wings is now doing like the thighs
because i can't get the wings anymore
yeah i don't know if it's that
particular brand one of the major brands
has changed to thighs because they can't
get the wings anymore
we we here at tim cass love awesome
b-dubs we do we had an argument ian was
right
so is it so is this is this personally
devastating news for you then
i'm gonna flip this whole table over
and this is how this affects your life
people we're on small business
right here but actually it may be the
most
important thing no no joke i mean look
going out to the bar watching a game
having wings and rings and whatever else
you can't get that
that's when people go hey wait a minute
hold on
you know if when people hear like it's
hard to get a computer chip so computers
are more expensive
they might go i don't know actually
there was a survey done
they asked people which about certain
products and whether or not the cost had
increased
and airplane tickets and electronics
people were unsure of and didn't know
but chicken wings and gas were way up
and they knew it and bacon too
so this is interesting i think of all of
the things that can be taken away
because of government failures
that impact small businesses they really
have to be careful because if they start
affecting
bacon supply that would be yeah tragic
it right
it is silly to think like haha bacon but
no i mean people wake up and have eggs
and bacon people go to mcdonald's and
get sausage and bacon people
eat these things they enjoy them things
the reason it's a joke is because we
know that people really love this stuff
if they can't find it they start asking
questions people start getting mad
and that's what you got to get worried
if you're the government yeah i mean but
it's about so much more than that i mean
it really is about our
economic freedom i mean i think people
when they think about
business and you say like how many big
businesses are out there and
i do this with people all the time like
i'll hear like oh like i think there's
like probably like a million and it's
like
no there's five thousand ish publicly
traded companies in the us
and there's like another five to seven
thousand maybe
maybe up to ten thousand there's like
between ten and fifteen thousand big
businesses in the us
their before covid was 30.2
million small businesses that account
for half the gdp and about half the
employment
so when we talk about this i think
people feel like this is like a niche
issue that doesn't really affect this is
a half the economy
and if you have to understand sort of
the thought process
behind this that if you are the
government and you're trying to usurp
power which they
have done in terms of how much they're
spending laws
you know purview everything else uh
if you're trying to deal with people
you're trying to get re-elected you're
trying to get campaign funds you're
trying to push legislation through
whatever it is
what is easier to do like get like 10
000 big businesses behind you or 30.2
million small businesses behind you this
is a nuisance we heard the banks were
too big to fail
they did they did awful things that
ended up screwing up the economy for all
of our lives
and they got a bailout yet
they closed small business by mandate
and they got crumbs because
not only are they too small to matter
but they're too hard to control
and that is the intention here like you
cannot walk away from this you cannot go
through this
and think it's not not intentional and
by the way even if you don't
the outcome is still just as bad but
this is intentional
is the intent to just steal wealth from
middle-class and working-class people it
it's to consolidate
power by any means what happens to those
people it doesn't matter
because they're not in the club if
you're not in the club
you don't matter you're just like you're
just pawns in the in the game
and so they have seen that we have
allowed them
to consolidate more and more power
i mean you have small businesses and
there are a couple of examples of small
business owners attilis jim shelly
luther and her salon alamo that i talk
about in the book
who said no you're not you're not gonna
take my property this is you're
infringing on my property rights and you
haven't compensated me for
it but a lot of people said well okay
there was something that happened to me
that that we we you briefly mentioned
hearing about before the show is
it's that i got denied a loan for a home
and that was shocking to me because look
i'm not trying to
be like a braggart we have a successful
company here and i wanted to get a
uh to get to get a small house very it's
relatively small the bank said no
and they sent false credit information
to me
it felt like i was just told you are not
allowed it was three months of run
around constantly asking for new
documents and something weird happened
maybe it was a bad company that could be
the case but we are seeing this thing
with blackrock
these these firms that just get
essentially free money from the fed
and they can outbid any working-class
person to buy up this property
and we're watching them buy a property
like crazy and then turn them into
rental properties
where we're we're going to end up having
the the millennial generation right now
entering their 40s right we're old
people at this point
they have kids the kids are going off to
college in some instances but they're
unable to own
property which means they're they're
going to have less wealth to transfer to
the next generation
they're not going to have something they
control not only that they're going to
be
beholden to student loan debt and to
their landlords
which are going to be big firms yeah and
if you think about
wealth creation and something that
obviously i spent a lot of time talking
about it the way that you
create wealth is through equity and when
i say equity i don't mean
equity in the sort of critical race
theory equity i mean in the financial
terms of equity having ownership in
something
so ways that you create equity you have
equity by
building a business good for you
american dream doing that
you may not sort of have the ability to
do that but you invest in the stock
market and you participate in the equity
increases of
other businesses maybe you work for a
private company and you're able to get
stock options so you've got to own a
piece of the business that you're
working for
you own a house and you get equity
ownership
is wealth creation and so limiting those
opportunities by government interference
in
the free market leads to less
wealth for everyone and that's the
frustrating part for me
my background we talked about being a
recovering investment banker but
i i'm the first person in my my
immediate family who graduated from
college
my dad was an electrician you know his
parents went through the great
depression and we're super poor and grew
up on the west side of chicago
that's where he grew up and so he you
came out of there
and worked really hard and saved up a
bunch of money and then sent me to
school and couldn't afford it so then i
had to pay down my college loans and so
on and so forth
but i've gotten to the point where i am
today which
nobody could believe because of this
american dream because of the system of
capitalism
and i've watched it over the course of
my career
from whether it's interference in the
stock market and you're seeing this
in the the ape community and the retail
investors who are trying to fight
back against you know the the the tilted
playing field in stock market
you're seeing this in small business
versus big business
you're seeing us move away from
capitalism
and we've exported it we exported it to
china to their benefits
and we've imported more central planning
to our detriment
and that is affecting the wealth
creation opportunities
because with capitalism the pie grows
and there's an abundance
ability for anybody to participate in
that
it's interesting i mean a lot of people
talk about a communist takeover here in
the united
states or cultural marxism and then we
think about the buying up of all these
properties
and how it will result in a generation
not probably not millennials maybe
necessarily gen z but certainly gen
alpha
is going to be a generation of renters
what happens when
there's an economic crash and not a
single individual
i should say for the most part 90 don't
own the property and can't pay their
rent
and then you get a massive government
intervention to a big firm saying we're
going to bail you out in exchange for
partial ownership and now
the government government becomes one of
the largest stakeholders
in owning all of the buildings that
people live in
it may not be communism but you're
certainly walking very close to the
government owning where you live
well or potentially that you have you
know all these dollars coming in from
china which we've seen happen as well
and you have
people who chinese you know chinese
people not american chinese people but
actual communist chinese
who are buying up properties as well
it's another possible way to
you know infiltrate and take over the
the country
by taking over the wealth creation
opportunities
yeah so i i have some articles i want to
show you real quick this one's from may
28th
forbes realtors will hate me for this
but here's five reasons why you
absolutely shouldn't buy a home right
now here's another one
millennia nearly two-thirds of
millennials have home buyer regrets
new survey says how about this one
millennials who snapped up homes in the
hot real estate market reveal their
biggest regrets
from unexpected costs to high mortgage
payments op ed
home prices are going through the roof
millennials piling the market is one big
driver
can we talk about the government
inflation piece of this as well so this
is really
fascinating uh may report from the
national association of home builders
said that government regulation adds
94 000. to the average
price of a new home built geez then go
take a look at property taxes and how
much
those continue to increase every year so
just the government itself
is adding more and more cost to
homeownership and
if you go back to the market dynamics of
supply and demand
how many times do people want to build
more housing
and they're not able to because of
zoning laws or nimby or you know
whatever it is
and so we have this constricted supply
of housing as well um and so you've got
all these ways that the government
is interfering in the market between the
fed between the government inflation
between the laws well it's these media
outlets
seem to be trying to discourage people
from owning homes as well right so
already you have it
very difficult for millennials to
compete with massive firms
now they're being persuaded by the media
don't don't buy a house oh they regret
all of it
this is one of the craziest things to me
this um this millennials buy homes and
regret it
i think these millennials i've said it
before if if you buy a house
if you save up for a down payment you
can get a what what's
can you do zero down right now i'm not
entirely sure i mean it used to be a big
thing
so i think that they've actually cracked
down quite a bit as as you know
they've actually made it more difficult
in many ways to get homes they're not
sort of doing this this free-for-all
that they did
um but as you know it always ends up
bifurcated where
people who you're like well how that
person get a house gets a house
um and then you know people who have
great credit and whatnot
are finding they have to jump through a
billion dollars yeah yeah for me
it was it was a three months of hoops
and they ultimately said no yeah but
uh i guess what i want to tell
millennials this message is
if you end up being able to buy a house
if you save up you enough you need
as much as you need for the down payment
maybe it's five percent so if it's like
a two thousand dollar house
you might only need ten grand and not an
easy feat for a lot of people but if you
can save up maybe you have a significant
other
if you don't like the house rental
management companies
can run it for you and you are a
homeowner and you're a landlord
it's crazy to me that they're trying to
tell people not to do this
it's it's it's going to create
corporations
companies that own the property and the
people who don't that's the direction
we're heading in
and i'm going to tell you man it's going
to be a dystopian future when people
don't own anything
that's that's that's the great reset
it's these articles where they're like
home ownership is bad people don't want
to is the most blatant manipulation
i've i've seen in the last two years
from corporate media about what we're
talking about the great reset and it's
sad that
more people don't know that this is
manipulation that this is
yeah that this is marketing and that
it's i mean they could just say
maybe buy a smaller house i mean part of
the issue is right is that we've kind of
gone to this mcmansion
kind of thing if you think about the
square footage of the houses that people
grew up in
back in the day well i'm older than you
but back back in my day when i walked to
school
uphill both ways um you know that the
houses were much smaller
and so we've we've kind of gone into
this place where there's bigger
but there's all different kinds of
options and so maybe it's yeah maybe you
don't need
the bigger house but still buy something
get equity get ownership
ownership leads to wealth we want to
encourage prosperity
for everyone we want everyone to be in
the game because if you don't have
everybody in the game
go ahead i was going to say um
the message that we espouse is empower
yourself yes the message that these
firms and the media says is
disempower yourself become weak give us
the power
you're the victim right exactly go on
the government ubi let the government
take
care of you let them give you twelve
thousand dollars a year because yeah
that's going to make you well it's not
logical that's what gets me is these
these messages this messaging is not
logical to tell people not to buy land
it's not logical
it's it's someone is doing this on
purpose you ever
you guys remember that viral video where
the guys like read a book
read a book read a mother fn book yes
and that is one part he's like buy some
land buy some land you're
spinning rims yeah buy some land man you
give that to your kids
when you go go follow on twitter wu tang
financial
oh my gosh yeah wu tang financial
they'll give you all these kinds of like
great
nuggets your kind of meme style but but
the the underlying message
absolutely and it you know maybe if the
housing
thing isn't for you then go get equity
in businesses build the business oh
except for the fact that when you go do
that
then you're going to get shut down the
government's your number one risk and
it's so interesting
the parallel between what happened with
big and small businesses
with the cares relief and what you're
talking about with the housing market
because what happened and you know we've
seen it in previous bailouts all this
money goes to big companies
the cares act was primarily trillions of
dollars to cronies who by the way didn't
have to do anything to get it they
didn't have to apply
but if you were a small business you had
to step up and apply
and the biggest small businesses kanye
west and tom brady
got ppp loans but your pizza shop down
the road didn't
and so you know how you said you had all
that paperwork that you had to fill out
it's the same thing for the small
business you had to jump through the
hoops they made it hard if you had a bad
background check
they said sorry you know we can't give
you the loan because
you've got bad debt they made it as hard
as possible for the people
who needed it the most who again did
nothing wrong this was government
mandate
taking their properties averting their
property rights
and they were the ones that had to jump
through the hoops is that because they
just assumed those businesses were going
to go out of business anyway they wanted
them out of business they didn't care
that that
that is just extra people riffraff that
can come onto the government dole
that can go work for amazon they want to
consolidate power this is
central planning versus decentralization
this is crypto
versus the fed this this is what's
happening retail versus the market this
this
is decentralization versus
centralization and then it comes back to
crypto you know why there is this um
move against it why many many
poor people are convinced to get away
from it why the articles say
china's cracking down dodge this don't
go near it
and it's an escape right that's how it's
been described by a lot of people who
had max kaiser on the show and he said
it gets you out of that system
maybe you can't own property but you can
own crypto and that's something they
can't control and boy do they not like
that
no they don't i mean and that's that's
potentially crypto's biggest risk right
now
is that you have a stock market that's
valued in dollars you have an irs that
takes payment in dollars
and you have a u.s government with us
the central bank's
pseudo attached to it that has a
military although the military's gone
woke so yeah maybe that's not as big of
a risk anymore
um but you know they don't want to give
up
that power they don't want somebody else
to
have that power and be in the in club
are you can they're going to do
everything they can to fight it
which is exactly why people are fighting
back against it which i think is great
and i think needs to happen
but that's where this is going to come
down to and so
that's what we need to be watching so
all of this stuff right the war on small
businesses
the the the telling people to buy houses
and taking other property what's the
future you see if this trend continues
so what's going to end up happening is
that you have
you have small businesses you're going
to have economic freedoms taken away
and you're going to have them taken away
and we've seen the seas planted it's
under the guise of capitalism
capitalism isn't working they tell you
we're in
late stage capital capitalism is just
freedom choice and transparency with
property rights
so there is no stages it's just kind of
like on a spectrum over here with free
choice
versus forced coercion and control and
so they're going to blame
capitalism they get people riled up and
go yeah you know you're right we should
probably
have the government in charge of more
things it's going to kill more
businesses
and you're going to end up with some
form of a
pseudo centrally planned hybrid economy
where maybe
you know amazon and you know 50 other
companies get a do their thing
and everything else is the government
and like you said you owe nothing you
have no wealth creation opportunities
and we have squandered
the biggest opportunity for economic
freedom that has ever
happened in history in the world what
scares me about all this is that
yes there's this idea you will own
nothing and you will be happy
but i don't believe that centralized
economies
or or command control and
authoritarianism actually work it's it's
this utopian pipe dream
some well history has proven that they
don't we don't have any example
anywhere in history that it's ever
worked so so yeah you don't just have to
believe it you could just follow the
data
so what happens is you get every what is
it every generation or
multiple generations you get some
crackpot despot saying
i should control everything because i'm
smarter than all them
and then they realize calculating the
economic requirements
of billions of people cannot be done by
a single mind or a committee or a
council
or a small firm it requires
decentralized economics or hey
free enterprise 100 100
i mean this this is and you go back to
basic economics by thomas sowell or
anything else
and and people making free choices
are going to tell the market what they
need and certainly
at any point in time there may be a
slight dislocation but it gets
it gets fixed i mean look at toilet
paper right what happened in march of
2020
we had a problem people decided to have
a run on toilet paper i don't know
why that was the like one thing if
there's going to be a pandemic that
you're worried about but people cared
about their behinds i have a bidet
wasn't a big deal to me um but i'm a i'm
always ahead of the car
so you know marco rubio goes out and he
writes an op-ed
and like one of the papers like oh well
we really need to be on top of the
supply chain the market figured it out
in a couple months
there was more toilet paper than anybody
wanted and certainly
there are going to be continued
disruptions when the government
intervenes
but if you let the market sort itself
out like it's going to
figure it out over time yes there's
going to be bad actors
there is bad actors in every system or
on system as i like to call capitalism
but you
you know you have rules and regulations
in place to take care of those specific
things that infringe on property rights
but there is never going to be a
committee of people
who have your best interest at heart i
mean that's the part that's that's the
worst is people seem to think
that there are these people sitting in
washington who want them to succeed
and that they're going to do what's
right for them over their own best
interest
that is just not human nature that's why
we're representative of
democracy doesn't work because those
people do not represent others they
represent themselves
and it's up to the individual to
represent themselves it's it's we're in
an
ancient system right it's back to milton
friedman you know where are you going to
find these angels to organize the
economy for us
and this is the part where it's like
both frustrating and exciting
because like i look at the people who
like with the former bernie bros and
progressives
and sort of the independents where i sit
and even some of the conservatives
and a lot of us are circling around the
same ideas guys like we have the same
issues we have the same problems we just
haven't quite gotten there on the
solution and so i hope that people
who may not you know who may think the
government is the right answer
takes a look at what the government's
been involved in
how many laws we have how much money
they're spending like what their
outcomes have been
and go oh my god we've got frankenstein
we've got to kill the monster here
and let's look at the other opportunity
is there a way
even if you don't if you think the
government somehow needs to be involved
is there a way to bring
more transparency and more free choice
to everything we do and keep the
government out of the way
one of the challenges is the media you
know we both love it we hate it
but you mentioned more choices if people
don't know something exists
or you know how do they find it how they
buy it and it's it's something that i
think
with steve jobs who said how do they
know they want it if they've you know
never seen it
so you have to you know explore and make
things but
to this point when it came to toilet
paper and the gasoline thing that
happened
just this past month or so with the
shortage local shortages
it was the media you know the media
started telling people toilet paper was
vanishing so people got up and ran to
the toilet
don't whatever you do don't buy
toilet paper i mean don't
buy toilet paper i mean do you have
stock in
charmin or something it's i'm short
charmander
it's like the fire alarm where it's like
don't pull
like all i want to do is just pull
anytime they tell me not to do something
or they tell you that it's going to be a
panic
like that's of course that's what's
going to set people off like this it's
like nobody understands human nature or
perhaps
they understand it very well and they're
manipulating you you're right
human nature is very interesting because
language is not literal
when you say don't get angry what people
are hearing is
calm get down they're literally hearing
get angry get angry the word don't's
there but they're hearing get angry get
angry
so it vibrates a different ang it makes
people get
so you want to say like be happy be
peaceful not don't be
angry it's a double negative it doesn't
work in language not spoken language
calm down calm down
any woman to calm down your marriage
will end
like they're on the spot like the two
least effective words together
in the human language is calm down i've
noticed if you tell people
you're happy you're listening to me then
they start to listen to you as opposed
to in a fight being like you're not
listening then they stop
then they're like i'm not listening okay
i'm not listening i'm not listening
and so you want to like create you know
positive yeah i mean this is what improv
is based off of
but fun fact me i actually studied with
second city
um and so i've got a little bit of
improv background and so one of the
things they teach you in improv is this
technique called yes and it's like the
you know kind of ground floor
where is when somebody says something
instead of like saying
no and like going direction you say yes
and
and then you go and you use that to
build a bridge to something and so it's
acknowledging
like yeah i hear what you have to say
and like let's bring this into the
discussion too it's just
it's the same thing but it's
communicated in a way that's more
inclusive
and makes people feel like like you're
taking and listening to them which
by the way at the end of the day a lot
of that's what a lot of this is about is
people just want to be heard
right i wanna i wanna jump to the store
and give a shout out to mr glenn
greenwald
oh yeah we have this story from uh well
we have a lot of daily wire
i'm sorry daily mail today fire brand
journalist glenn greenwald
slams msnbc and cnn for dangerous
failure
failure to investigate issues and
praises fox as the only news outlet
presenting an opposite opinion
it's crazy that we're in this era cause
i grew up with fox news being the bad
ones
that was weird and ideologically
homogeneous
but now it's it's true i mean you look
at msnbc and cnn
and if the government said it it's true
that's it fox you know tucker carlson he
brings on antifa
and the funny thing is so i i know these
activists these old hackers they posted
a photo today of themselves with glenn
greenwald and they were like
just disparaging their young cells
saying it's not our fault we didn't
change and i'm like yo like
these people used to be fans of glenn
greenwald fans of wikileaks
now they're actively defending the fbi
and msnbc and cnn like how does this
happen
this shift so i'll tell you what
happened is people have abandoned and
i don't know maybe that never existed
but it's really gone i think with social
media in the other direction they've
abandoned the concept of principles
everything is party it's politics it's
people but it's not principal so i'm on
the team
you know either this is my sports team
or it's my religion or
whatever it is and like no matter what
it is
if it's coming from my arena i'm gonna
agree it's good
and i'm not saying that you know i don't
have a set of principles that i'm
judging things against and so
i mean you see this all the time they do
the man on the street segments where you
tell somebody
a statement and you put a different name
attached and all of a sudden they don't
agree with the statement anymore
we got to get back to just people you
don't like
can say things that are interesting and
make sense and people you do like
can say things that you don't agree with
or you think that are completely
insane and it is it is every side of the
coin it is the left is the right
the easiest content you'll see it from
jimmy kimmel he goes outside and says
something like
you know donald trump said this and then
he'll get dumb people to say dumb things
and then go ha ha look how dumb trump
supporters are but then you'll see the
same thing for people on the right
where they'll go out and say things like
you know barack obama said x and they'll
cheer for ah that was donald trump
or you get a lot of people who will be
like look how dumb these liberals are
and things like that
i do think the tendency tends to be on
the left however and in the mainstream
press
i think for whatever whatever reason
right now you'll find on the right with
trump supporters with conservatives
republicans
there's typically more honesty and more
attempt at good faith conversation
for example you know stephen crowder
trying to have a conversation with ethan
klein
and ethan klein's response as we see
with the mainstream in the left was to
make it a spectacle
to turn it into a bad faith troll and
then
the four was in daily beast and newsweek
all laugh and hoot and yell
aha we got you crowder crowder was
trying to have a good faith conversation
so so i don't know what it is because it
felt like when i was growing up the left
was trying to be good faith
but maybe that was just me being in the
matrix
it's very possible i mean i grew up in a
non-political family
i didn't know about any of this like i
completely felt
completely tushy backwards into this
when mitt romney ran for president
because they needed somebody to explain
the auto bailouts and and all those
kinds of things and private equity was a
private equity guy
um and so they're like you're an
investment banker like you come out i
just want to be a game show host
people that's what i did i wanted to
give away pride i still want to be a
game show host
but somehow i got like dragged into this
and so like
you know i didn't you know i just
basically whatever my parents said like
yeah okay but they weren't really even
they didn't really follow any of this
stuff and then you kind of get in the
middle of it and you're like
the heck is going on but the craziest
part about all of this is just the guilt
by association
and the cancel culture whether you do it
yourself or whether it's you know you've
got somebody on the back of your book
that some corporation doesn't like
and now they're not buying your books
anymore couple days before book launch
not that this
happened it didn't happen did it did it
happen
so this this is breaking news you could
be the first people to hear about this
um and this is so disappointing because
it's like one person who's not even
in the organization so i'm not going to
name the organization because i like the
organization
it's a big big old company who wanted to
have me
come out and give a speech and instead
of charging my speaking fee i said well
if you buy
the equivalent amount of the books then
you can give everybody a book and you
know well
win-win for everyone oh this is great
and they're tagging publicist we're
working out the details
well one outside pr consultant looked at
the six
different names on the back of the book
that represent
all different viewpoints because that's
a great thing about small business it
brings people together
and they didn't like one of the names
and they
thought that that tainted me and blew
up the entire thing and i'm like how is
it the fact that i'm building
bridges and bringing together different
viewpoints a
bad thing you would think that's exactly
what we need
at this point in time about a topic that
again like i don't even talk about it
you can talk about whatever you want
you're buying my books like you're
i'm on your clock i can talk about
anything i talk about football hockey i
don't really care
so they could have done anything or they
could have
but like i'm now cancelled and my book
orders are literally
cancelled because they pulled out one of
the six names one person
a outside pr person didn't
want that association if you knew
that that name would have had would have
resulted in this circumstance would you
remove it no
because i am in the fortunate position
where i can make those decisions and
i've told people before like
i'm getting the vans on the book anyway
like i don't care if it sells one copy
or whatever i'm not doing this
for financial needs i'm doing this
because it's a really important message
that everybody needs to hear they need
to just to spread
and also if this book doesn't do well
nobody's going to do
anything about small business in the
media again because i don't know if you
guys know this
probably not because this is my domain
but like
anyway so this is the entry so this is
the entry
just for people to say we care about
small business
and you know but they're trying to take
that away well let's think about that
for a second um
i think he did the right i think that
was the right thing if if it were me i
would not remove the name of any comment
or endorsement simply because someone
would threaten to cancel me so
i think you you're saying the right
thing i agree with you but there's also
the argument that
couldn't you have reached more ears by
you
canceling one of those endorsements
yeah it's i mean it goes back to
principle it's just not the way that i
roll i'm hoping that i can
can find a different way let me tell you
a story about my last book
because i think this will give you this
will give you a little sense of who i am
so
when i wrote my last book the
entrepreneur equation my
publisher at the time had the idea of
putting a picture of me on the book
cover
and if you've seen the book cover it's
me and pink heels in front of a
chalkboard doing a little like sexy
teacher kind of thing
or whatever they they conceptualized it
and back in the day there were actually
bookstores
and one of the big bookstores uh one of
the buyers told my publisher
you know she's a little too attractive
to be taken seriously as a business
author
so we kind of think you should either
pull her off the cover of the book
or you know maybe like uglier up a
little bit and so they came back to me
with this feedback
and they said you know by the way my
last publisher was very very
collaborative they were great
and i said it's your book but these guys
are really important so like what do you
want to do
i said well not only am i going to do
this but i'm going to do the biggest
blank blank to them of all time and for
those of you who know i have my own
fashion doll slash action figure
that was made as a premium to match what
i look like on the book cover and so for
every book that was sent out
the action figure was sent with it and i
just kind of doubled down on that and
said that was the thing
so that's kind of how i approach it but
again i have the ability to
do that when somebody does care
about like that book sale is going to
put food on the table they don't have
the flexibility to make the same choices
that i do and so i'm cognizant which is
why
i care about these topics because not
everybody can do that
it's a big challenge yeah knowing that
there is this
system in place that is is uh
unreasonable
and that's that that this story is kind
of nuts like
without saying with the person is it is
a mainstream normal person it is
totally crazy that a company would be
like i don't know about that guy
i actually had um right i mean it's not
like i've got like
like manson on the cover like like oh
you should really i mean yeah these are
all these are all well-known people you
may not agree with them
but yeah i actually had uh the daily
beasts wrote an article about the uh
john mcafee thing and i i tweeted uh
bowl effing ish
in response to the story and i linked
john mcafee saying i would never take my
own life
and so they incorporate that into the
story which i don't care they call me a
conspiracy theorist it's like okay if i
was making i
i didn't make an assertion about what
happened i just said bs like i don't
believe the story
not believing a story is not asserting a
conspiracy but they called me alt-right
it said i was all right and i'm like
they just make it up i got called out
right for this too
yeah so literally because i had one
person they didn't like on the book
which is like hilarious because like i'm
an independent
like jewish woman like my old friend
it's because they know it'll taint in in
the future someone will look back
now i was fortunate enough look i i i go
i go through things in the very normal
way i don't go on twitter and start
screaming like this is ridiculous
quiet email requesting a retraction and
a correction
and they immediately responded with an
apology and took it out hmm
i'm lucky that happened good for you
because a lot of there there was there
was one period where they there was
you know they lie about people all day
and night and
i think the scary thing is that for you
mentioned the little guy
doesn't have the opportunity to make
these these choices
what are you supposed to do when you're
going up against a multi-million dollar
corporation that's lied about you
and there's not much you can do so i
look at it this way as well um
i was flying on american airlines once
and our
flight got delayed because of a major
storm it was in i think it was in dallas
and so i went i i
went on twitter and you know tweeted i'm
like hey is there any update on this i
couldn't get through the phone line
and the next thing i know they're like
mr pool we're going to take care of you
and make sure everything is perfect
step to the line right now and let them
know when i walk with the line i look to
my right
huge line hundreds of people waiting and
i'm like this kind of screwed up
they because they don't fear the regular
person who can't do anything about their
circumstances but they're worried i
could tweet and cause them problems
i don't like that idea i don't like
tweeting at companies but sometimes the
only way to get them to react well it's
interesting so
tying it back into what happened you
know with coven and small business and
ppp
you know this is exactly where the
structure of ppp failed so badly is that
they put
you know these parameters where you
could have you know millions and
millions of dollars in
assets and revenue and you could still
you go in and apply for these ppp comp
or ppp loans so if you're a bank and
you've got like
the guy who's got millions of dollars
and you've been doing business with
them and then you've got like this pizza
shop that's like struggling to make it
like whose loan are you going to fulfill
first of course you're going to fulfill
your good customer
it should have they've never should
never been put in that position in the
first place and so that goes back to a
flaw in the structure it's hard
to fault the person who has the loyal
relationship whose business is also
going to depend on it
but why was it structured that way to
begin with and i think those are the
questions we need to continue to ask
we need smart contracts to dole out
these things like um this is
part of the great thing about
cryptocurrency is there's no middleman
to decide where what's going to happen
where it's going to go you have the
parameters and
it fits and there it is on in the on the
blockchain out in the open
which is why is it why it's a threat to
them i have some i'm optimistic
you know a couple days ago we were
talking to bannon he was saying
we're winning once these these moms see
what hap what happens to their kids what
these schools are teaching on august
15th it's going to be it's going to be
crazy and that was a really really good
point i'm also confident because of the
things we're doing over at timcast.com
and the tremendous
support we have from all of you who are
members you guys are amazing
we're able to hire journalists we're
expanding like crazy things are going
better
than ever we're trying really hard to
move away from youtube because that was
putting all our eggs in one basket it's
very very dangerous
we're trying to build something
substantive and so i'm confident that
not only are we going to succeed with
the support of our paying members
we're finding new ways to generate
revenue new ways to uh support real news
and fact check
and all of that makes me optimistic and
there's another thing that makes me
really optimistic is seeing stories like
this one
brian stelter's revised anti-trump
diatribe hoax
tanks with less than 2 000 copies sold
in its first week
despite massive book tour and launch
party as ratings for his cnn show
dropped to its lowest
of the year seeing this happen he sold
1738 copies in his first week
wow that's very very very few so so
here's the thing is that i guess
when people hate watch a show they don't
hate buy the book i mean because i mean
that's i mean and again i don't like to
pick on people's livelihoods but i do
feel like
based on everything i've seen there are
a lot of people who
watch the show that most of the
commentary isn't oh i'm enjoying this
thing it's literally hate watching it
seems like that's the the big part of
his audience which i think is hard to
translate
at the same time i'm not gonna make fun
of that number of book sales because
you know i've got a book that's coming
out i've got big corporate media
who doesn't want to cover it i've got
big corporations who are canceling me so
i might do worse than brian's delter
sure sure but this is this is a guy who
goes on tv and he tells people not to
watch other shows
he's got this massive cnn platform
that's ratings are in decline
and now he can't sell his book i mean
this is a guy who was getting over a
million viewers
now he's getting around seven eight
hundred thousand it's going down hey
that's still a lot of viewers weighs
more than i'm getting
but you see that decline at the same
time it it
look i'm not trying to there is a bit of
i guess
spite in like ha ha watching someone
fail and everything like that
but i genuinely think what he does is is
dangerous what cnn does is bad
they lie they manipulate they're part of
the problem
and they represent the decentralized
media i'm going to give a plug to you
right now centralized media right
the centralized media and you are the
decentralization and so i mean if you're
enjoying this
you should be supporting tim and i'm
going to support you because i believe
in this
because decentralization is critical and
this
is the american dream and capitalism is
about putting your dollars
where your belief system is you can't go
out and say you know
alexa why does jeff bezos have so much
money
could you order me some doritos and tell
me the sales on prime days and then go
like well what you know what's going on
she's gonna be like i can't talk about
that okay she we actually have one and
you call her but she didn't respond you
can ask her all sorts of questions about
jeff
she's like okay i'm not gonna talk about
it but that's what i'm saying is that so
you so
so support the things that you believe
in and support these small
companies and support small business and
support small business advocacy
that's how you make a dent and and don't
support don't don't hate watch
things you don't like because it's
giving them dollars i mean i know
it's fun and whatever but like don't do
it support the things like let's make it
a positive instead of a negative
and go out and support because you are
the american dream you're building
that you're helping other people with
them
getting more jobs and creating something
that's important and we need more of
that
and people should should buy your book
the war on small business by carol roth
why
amazon is one of the most powerful ways
that decentralized media has been able
to get a foothold and challenge the
establishment
i mentioned this the other day with
michael knowles books speechless
definitely you should buy speechless you
should buy
unmasked by andy noah pacific's book
jackpot's book um
antique that's the answer yeah oh yeah
because when people go to amazon
and michael malus's book the anarchist
handbook create space i believe is where
it is you can you can publish your own
books
you go on amazon and you'll see the top
charts and it's a bunch of
anti-establishment thinkers it's people
challenging conventional wisdom with
with interesting ideas
and they don't all agree with each other
but it's it's a way to break through
when the establishment the mainstream
when cnn when they don't give the time
of day
when brian selter comes on tv and says
don't watch the spin come to us
when was it tapper who said you can't
read wikileaks emails only we are it's
illegal only we can read it
you can now find the honest and
dissenting voices because
amazon has to put them in the ranking
same as everybody else
granted they do ban books which is
another scary component of this but so
long as we have that opportunity
if everybody buys your book we can get
this top 10 list which is going to
include a bunch of people of varying
political ideologies
and that will what will happen is a
regular person will be browsing amazon
where they see number one they see carol
roth number
number number one they say michael
knowles or andy no or people like ben
shapiro or dave rubin
and now they're gonna get an idea they
normally wouldn't have got from
cnn so this is so interesting so that
this is a good um sort of capitalism
debate
because i had been directing people to
bookshop.org
because i don't know if you're familiar
with bookshop.org but what it does
is it fulfills books from local small
business book sellers
so you get a not only support small
business advocacy in terms of
the book that you're buying and learning
these concepts and spreading the
concepts but you actually get it put a
couple dollars towards
the small business but it's an
interesting point
because at the same time if it doesn't
chart well
on amazon then the people outside the
ones who are buying it here
also don't get so i need you to buy two
books could you buy one
on amazon and buy one on bookshop give
it to a friend
no but seriously um but it is an
interesting sort of question is do you
want to
like do you to take down and get some
foothold
do you need to chart on the big place
and you know
change minds or do we support the small
guys
and win in that direction and maybe
they're not mutually exclusive no i
don't think they are i think you should
support both yeah
i want to rub cnn's nose in it a little
bit because i got the story okay okay
this is important guys
i need to beat brian stelter so even if
you
don't care about this book i can't sell
fewer copies than he does
well no no i'm gonna bring up a costume
so this is a story from two years ago
president donald trump cnn's jim acosta
spar over journalists book sales granted
from 2019 it's still kind of funny so
trump is talking and then they say
um he was asked about uh muhammad bin
salman
and then trump flips the script saying i
don't really care about offending people
i sort of thought you know that
flips the script and says by the way
congratulate to jim acosta by the way
by the way congratulations i understand
your book is it doing well
it's doing very well mr president acosta
said trump seemed astonished
really i'll get you an autographed copy
acosta offered
it's from deadline by the way not from
fox news they say
acosta's book isn't doing that well it's
in the 1300s on amazon
he was previously zinged on the lagging
sales by fox news sean hannity who
called the book a disaster and an
epic fail so yes like you said it's
people watch these shows because they
hate trump or they hate the right
not because they like acosta's reporting
not because they like brian stelter
so when the name pops up that says
seltzer they say i don't care
if the if the if the book was why trump
is bad by guy who hates trump
they might actually buy that book yeah
well and it's my only again my issue
on principle and not personage is that
he's got a show called reliable sources
that does not have reliable sources and
so if you
run a show that's not named correctly
and your book is called hoaxed i don't
really know what i'm getting inside the
book
yeah let's let's let's jump to a story
by the way it's laughing yeah
that's true it's true you have no idea
what to do
we'll we'll we'll just do a hard segue
into this mumford and sons thing
through this one yeah so we had the
story from timcast.com by cassandra
fairbanks mumford and sons guitarist
leaves band after outrage over him
praising andy noe's book
it's kind of a crazy story it's a roller
coaster of emotion
they say following intense backlash
after he he prays and he knows
book he apologized for endorsing the
book over the past few days i have come
to better understand the pain caused by
the book i endorsed
i have offended not only a lot of people
i don't know but also those closest to
me including my bandmates and for that i
am truly sorry
as a result of my actions i am taking
time away from the band to examine my
blind spots for now please know that i
realize how my endorsements have the
potential to be viewed as a approvals of
hateful
divisive behavior i apologize the
apology tweet
which was put out in march has now been
deleted on thursday he wrote a medium
post explaining his decision to leave
the band
saying that he wants to be free to speak
his mind
he mentioned that it wasn't just the
endorsement that was the problem
he goes on to mention that actually
apologizing
was the next sin that caused the mob to
come after him
so i find this to be actually an
interesting story because it shows that
when you're confronted with an angry mob
there's nothing you can do
so it's what should someone do cause
look it's not just the left
now we we typically say the left is all
about cancel culture but it affects the
right as well
i mean listen i just have a thing in
life and my husband will tell you this
this is like the one thing that drives
him crazy about me i will not apologize
for something
if i'm not sorry so like my husband gets
like two upon
she's a year on things there are a
couple of times when i do things but
most of the time there's someone's like
no i'm not
i'm not sorry i'm not apologizing you
don't apologize
if you're not sorry for something and
you shouldn't be sorry
for speaking and having a differing
opinion no my version of apology is to
change my behavior
if i really am sorry for what i did i'm
going to make sure i don't do it again
and i'm going to do something better
that's
i'm not going to what makes crime yell
about what's also what's this thing
about apologizing to
people that have nothing to do with it
like you to me if you wrong
somebody if i wrong you tim i'm sorry to
you but i don't even apologize to the
rest of the world that like this is
between the two of us this is a very
personal thing
like why have we dragged everybody else
in the peanut gallery
into this concept of apologizing like i
don't apologize to you nothing to do
with it this was between the two of us
like
this is a very personal thing that
everyone wants to get in the middle of
virtue signaling it seems like
well so shout out apology to the
atmosphere when when this bumper and
sons guy
says you know hey andy great book you're
very brave
all of these people get mad saying
you're supporting the far right
so they are personally offended and they
demand he apologize
no i understand that they're personally
offended but has nothing to do with them
they did he didn't tweet something to
them so he can't be sorry
to them you can't take into account
every single person
like you know to take the temperature of
every person that's why we have the
concept of free speech right
the the main issue i suppose is that the
what's what really happens if you step
back is that mumford and sons was set to
lose money
and so he's like a bunch of people are
mad at me for doing a thing
i don't understand if i do nothing and
we lose money
so he apologizes the apology didn't work
they lose money no matter what so then
he says wow apologizing was a big
mistake which is funny because
you know look my question i'll throw
i'll throw it back to you and what makes
you sorry for something right you said
if you did something
and then you were actually sorry you'd
say you're sorry empathy it's if i see
that you're hurt
i i feel that and i want to make sure
you don't feel that again
but what if people are hurt for
something nonsensical like he
recommended a book or he didn't even
recommend he just said
great job then i still empathize with
your pain but i will let you know i'm
not going to change my behavior because
this is why i feel it's righteous well
and let me tell you about the money
angle too this is very
interesting because i at one point was
going to write a book kind of about the
the actual financial implications of
these
outrages and people get very angry
and they say we're going to boycott
something and then they move on
and so if you think about soul cycle or
you think about you know all these
different companies that have gotten
caught
up i know very few of them
that have have had you know those kinds
of financial implications because people
were outraged now
there are some like major cancel culture
issues that have some
short-term implications but a lot of
times when you have these like big
brand things like oh i'm not gonna go to
solo cycle anymore
like when's the last time you got on a
spin bike like never yeah so it's a lot
of times
it's this vocal minority that has
nothing to do with your fan base now
granted
if it's literally your fan base then
maybe you need to think about it
but a lot of times it's just like a
bunch of the course of trolls
and then they like move on to something
else next week and so i think a lot of
times people panic instead of just
letting it
blow over let's yeah so look we'll think
about the ramifications of you know
offending a fan base
should you just be especially in
politics a personality that just
says whatever your audience wants to
hear because then they'll give you money
or if you say something that offends
them should you just be like well that's
what i think have a nice day
even if you lose money well i think you
need to be careful as a
business or as somebody if you're like
fan driven or customer driven
like is do you want to have
a public set of opinions or do you want
to keep that
in your circle because you know reality
is like when back in my day when i
walked up hill to school
like the people who knew my opinions
were like a couple people in my circle
now we have dear diary that's twitter
and facebook we take
everything that we think and we
broadcast it to everybody
we weren't meant to take out information
so if you're in that
kind of public light and this isn't like
what you do for a living
then you might just say you know as a
policy like maybe i don't want to
comment
on these kinds of things publicly or
maybe i'm going to send a note to andy
privately or you know whatever it is
and it's not because you're scared or
you're bad or you're backing down
but it's just that's that's not how you
make a living that's not your
thing and not that you should have to
censor yourself i'm not trying to talk
about censorship but i'm just saying
like it
do we need to have everybody's opinion
about everything it's you're talking
about restraint and it's something that
is
maybe you could argue is lacking in
society but it is a detrimental it is a
very important
aspect of being a human is restraining
your body it is a wild animal that you
are in control of
and it wants to do things so you need to
be intelligent and of course
control yourself you don't need to tell
everyone everything that's not the
definition of honesty
the honesty is not lying to people but
you know it's just you use discretion
or it also stands so angry and also
staying because he's in a band i'm sorry
to interrupt you this guy's a musician
man and so am i and this is so
messed up that's all thank you yeah no i
mean and i think it's also just about
like sometimes just staying in your lane
not to say that the book thing isn't
staying in your lane but just
as a broader macro concept we're talking
about through the nuance of this
is that like you know i i'm an expert on
economic fine and financial things
like people who don't know the
difference between a balance sheet and
an income statement like want to come
argue with me about stuff and it's like
i don't need your opinion on how to
organize the economy you don't know what
a balance sheet is
so it's the same kind of thing i'm not
going to wade into like
discussing the intricacies of like
medical decisions or you know those
kinds of things that aren't my areas of
expertise
i don't think and part of it is this is
just a nascent technology we're not used
to
this level of communication so i'm not
judging anyone this is we're all trying
to sort this out and wait it through
but like not everybody needs to weigh in
on every topic
like pick the things where you
particularly have that domain expertise
and you know maybe spend more time
listening on some of the other things
there's no upside to twitter
there's there's literally none well the
other side is the connections right like
that i've met some of the most amazing
people i mean we met
because of twitter we met each twitter
we met because of him but because i saw
one of your tweets last night
because of twitter you know a lot of the
people are watching like i've met the
most amazing
connections and i've collaborated and
worked that is the upside to twitter but
you have to curate
that experience appropriately yeah i
i'll i'll walk that back for sure
there the upside definitely is
connections um like my my
uh communication with joe rogan which
resulted me me going on the show was
he was following me on twitter he damned
me we talked and
yeah i think before twitter it was you
couldn't communicate with with high
profile individuals or celebrities
it was just near impossible but i do
think something interesting is happening
where
i think there is a push towards
because of things like mumford and sons
the celebrities are once again
retreating from the landscape saying
there's no point
and what happens is it becomes
journalists or i should say activists
so the largest component the largest
community on twitter for the longest
time has been
journalists arguing with each other
that's the biggest component of the blue
checks too right right
yeah it's like a quarter of them or at
least this was several years ago
and so they argue about things in
culture and politics
and it literally makes their careers
they get a bunch of followers
then the news outlets are like oh you
have 20 000 followers welcome aboard
we'll hire you no no joke these news
outlets will be like
looking at some new hires i want to be a
writer well how many followers do you
have
because you bring that audience to them
and they know that you can push stories
out
get more traffic make them more money so
their goal for many of many of these
people is to say offensive things but
say them tribalistically which brings us
to
the i i think the problem one of the
biggest problems we're facing right now
is
mumford and sons as you say shouldn't
wade into this territory necessarily
because
this guy doesn't know anything about
antifa politics and so by him expressing
an opinion in favor of andy
it's not his area of expertise he
exposes himself the other issue is that
when it comes to the culture war you
basically have
one main rule say what your tribe wants
to hear or else
people actually we see it all the time i
mean mike cernovich tweeted all the time
where people are like i'm going to
unfollow you if you have a bad opinion
or
i'm not going to support your book and
then he just says bye-bye yeah right
but that's not what he retweets them and
says hey see you later here's the
attention that you ordered
i love their their someone made the meme
of you know the virgin and the chad
and it was like the the the the virgin
i'm gonna unfollow you and there was a
chat
i'll follow you for opinions i don't
like but it really does come down to
that because i i don't think it matters
whether you're on the left or the right
you will get the same kind of pressure
if you go against the tribe now the
issue i suppose is
the left tends to be dominant in
establishment culture so they have way
more power
if you are james gunn you know you are
the rare exception where the right was
able to get him
temporarily cancelled but on the left i
mean
they they can send a turn a tweet from a
guy with 100 followers into
destroying someone's life so so that
ties back into sort of big tech and the
algorithm
i'm sure that any of you who are on
twitter have noticed
the kinds of things that trend are
always
bad negative baby types of things i mean
even
a lot of times they have the tweet level
underneath them and you'll see
something where it's got like a thousand
tweets or whatever
and it's like you know put right up
there in the trend so that people can
see it
and a lot of times it's calling out
people by name and it's you know
that's the algorithm there they could
put up positive stories right you could
trend
positive stories but that's not what
they choose
to put at the top of the algorithm and
we know it's not
just based on the the data and who's
talking about it because you can see the
number of tweets and there are things
that have lots of tweets that you know
kind of don't
register and there are things that have
very few tweets that all of a sudden
like oh you might be interested in this
take a little take a little smell of
this what do you think about that
what is up with people's obsession with
with drama and gossip and
all that human nature why is that i mean
i guess it goes back
to nature tribes yeah like trump's
talking about is that
is that hunter a bad guy really like is
he gonna hurt us do we need to take him
out so they would gossip about their
tribe i guess and now it's like
all across the world on twitter i mean
yeah yeah twitter for sure
and it's be it's it's taken over
political discourse and politics where
we should be discussing what businesses
are doing how it's negatively impacting
um what government is doing this
negatively impacting small business how
it's impacting someone's life
but you'll end up with a lot of people
in the space who are more interested
in i'm not going to say the guy's name
but ambushing steven crowder
instead of actually having a legitimate
conversation and turning into a drama
moment for some clicks
and then you see newsweek you know
coming out and being like oh
and it's like newsweek you're supposed
to be at a prestigious magazine
you'll get you'll get people who will
like see a tweet from someone and be
like this
is what we should all be talking about
and it's like half the time
these tweets are from people who are
just sitting there like on their toilet
and they're like
and like you've got the most
breakthrough in science it's the most
epic breakthroughs in science ever seen
in witnessed by humanity in the last 20
years and like i i don't see much laser
spectroscopy advancement quantum you
know microscopes that are now able to
see 33 percent better it's there's a new
microscope that
hits cells without heat so it can see it
like 25 percent more clearly it's like
this this is but millions millions of
small businesses have been either
directly murdered or
like on life support and they want to
talk about
the drama what's the solution
i mean it goes back to us right at the
end of the day this is
like we're the ones that have to
safeguard freedom or the ones that have
to make better choices i mean your
twitter feed
literally is your own curation you can
curate it
any way you want you can decide who to
follow you can decide how to engage i
was sharing with you guys offline that
like one of the my best decisions for my
mental health on twitter
was to not respond to like provoking
questions or explanations
because it's just not a format in 280
characters
to have that rich nuanced dialogue there
are people there
other followers who will jump in and
have that and do that for them but like
for me that doesn't work
i'm an empath i'm a problem solver like
that's that's not a good combination
so i just think we need in every aspect
we just need to be more
intentional i mean we're so lucky to be
living
where we are and in this time and this
place in history and we just take
everything for granted and so we don't
put the dollars
towards the small business entities we
don't
curate more positivity and lift up more
people in our twitter feed we don't
empower people to make better decisions
i mean at the end of the day america is
great
because of us it's not because of our
government or
even because of a piece of paper in
spite of government
you know yeah well let's uh let's read
some super chats if you haven't already
friends you can smash that like button
and send your super chats this way you
can also go to timcast.com become a
member to support our fierce and
independent detainerism
and the unsolved mystery stuff where um
i probably shouldn't have said it
because we're so preliminary
about like doing an investigation into
the lost confederate goal
next week where are you tim i can't wait
i've been waiting for it you talked
about it a week ago where is it yeah oh
we got somebody on it
yeah i want to sit in a room made of
gold and just vibrate
i want to know i want to know wait i
want to go back to the lost confederate
gold
so if you find the confederate gold is
that cancelled
the goal itself because it's confederate
gold i think it would go to a museum
interesting yeah i think it i think it
should be you know they used to have air
ships
i would be happy to manage it
read some super chats okay super chat
and again we'll have a bonus segment up
at timecast.com so smash that like
button
gd superfan says at least we don't have
to read mean tweets anymore there is
that
there you go jay says we need a comedian
with the courage to make fun of the ccp
i got the idea that they are a high
school
they're a high school student who is
jealous that the us is the popular one
they're starting rumors to hurt the us's
popularity that's funny i like that
all right max doll says yo it's the
chick in the suit from twitter
anyway would either of you bet serious
money on kamala being president by the
end of 2022 god help us all yes i would
really
i'm not a betting woman i'm a
risk-adjusted returns kind of lady
what's the risk on on that bet the risk
is everything
we don't know right infra information
fits into risk
and there are a lot of things we don't
know there and so
i don't have enough information i only i
only bet when i if you ever watch me
playing cards and i go in
like you know i'm gonna win because i i
only i play it like that
all right tyler thomas says is there a
timcast.com mobile app in our future yes
there is
and it will have the ability to play
audio when it your phone is off like not
off but
asleep is that the right phrase yeah so
you can put in your pocket and not drain
your battery and then still here
i know right now we have the members
only thing but it's basically like a
browser function
and it's preliminary but the new the new
website is about it's the alpha will be
ready in only a few days and then we
gotta do the tests on it yes and then we
should have it up around
um i'm hoping fourth of july weekend but
i'm excited yeah often takes longer
yeah it always takes longer but but we
we did a rush
order say the least and it's it's costly
but i'm like we got to make sure this is
working because
look i'll say it man we i was completely
overwhelmed with the amount of support
we got
when we launched the website and you
know i guess after the first
the first two weeks seeing how many
people signed up and it's it's
i don't know if i should say it but it's
it's massive it's ridiculously massive
so i was like i think we need to use
this opportunity to hire journalists
immediately
make a much much stronger more powerful
website with a big company
start doing movies shows and we can make
something really big with this it's a
huge opportunity and i'm eternally
grateful to everybody who became members
so if you don't like me well
maybe you like assange fairbanks if you
don't like her but you do like me well
then you see
i'm trying to bring in an eclectic group
and it won't just be about whether you
like my opinion or not
because we're going to have content for
everybody we want to build culture and
do really amazing stuff so yes that is
coming and you're supporting
the american dream you're supporting
decentralization
you're supporting economic freedom and
independence and you are voting
with your dollars like this is an
amazing opportunity to support
there are no investors there is no
outside funding
i've had people come here and say so who
who you know how does this house is
funded and i say it's just me
like anything just you i'm like yeah
only me it's the way to do it it's an
american dream
this is this is what people come here
from everywhere around the world to do
companies become so much more agile and
functionable when they don't have
outside investment from my experience
i've built
companies i mean more or less i've
worked with maker studios in the early
days and i helped build mines from the
ground up and not
having tim as agile as he is it's
incredible the value of this company
just because of
the solo the solo investment it's
amazing
all right taternub says why fantasize
about the dystopian future when we could
bask in the dystopian present
history books are going to be far better
than fiction ever was
that's a good point yeah 1984 was not
supposed to be a how-to manual right
hey but it's fun and i gotta say i've
been a bit more optimistic lately
especially i i
that that that interview we did with
steve bannon was i thought that was
amazing he was
very very that's worth subscribing to
the website alone to see the after thing
with bannon man that was great
and let me also say you know this on
this online
um retail revolution ape community and
whatnot
also a lot of optimism there because
think about how far that's come from
occupy wall street 1.0
instead of just standing in the streets
kind of disorganized like ah we don't
bad but we don't know what they're
actually putting their money where their
mouth is they're saying we want to
participate
in the wealth creation that is such an
optimistic
step in the right direction and getting
more people involved
in the wealth creation process and now
we just need more resources and more
people to step up and empower them right
on wolfstar says
here is a test tim will you accept money
from someone who
who uses is nameless on youtube you'll
take my money but won't accept my
opinions how hypocritical
because it's nameless people with
opinions who support this is interesting
it's based on
uh uh this tweet i made where it was uh
literally a subtweet but i tweeted um
stop responding to people who don't use
their name
and have and don't use a real avatar and
you'll see political discourse improve
and boy did this like have a mixed
response a lot of retweets but
it was it was not the biggest ratio in
the world but i got rationed on this
and then i had people being like uh one
individual made a youtube video claiming
i was telling people to dox themselves
and i was having a meltdown over this
and i'm like i gotta be honest i was
like uh what was i watching i was trying
something i was watching outer limits
i'm sitting on my couch and i'm just
like my like drill coming on my mouth
like i was eating italian beef sandwich
and i'm just like
and then all of a sudden people are like
storming and raging and i'm like
whatever
i'm not going to apologize i won't
apologize to leftists i want to
apologize to people who want to be you
know
nameless avatars on the internet my
point was very simply if i'm going to
engage in discourse with somebody
but i'm visibly present with my name
behind all of my words
the discourse is typically better when
the other individual has the same levels
of exposure and risk as you because when
people don't
they can say a whole lot of crazy things
knowing they will never face any
repercussions
they have put nothing on the line to
make those statements i understand
anonymity is very very important
i i did a threat about the founding
fathers which was partially related but
kind of not really it's because i saw
this meme there's a meme that goes
around talking about
all the sacrifices made by the founding
fathers we're having a conversation
about juneteenth so all the stuff's in
my mind
and all of a sudden i'm hearing that i'm
against anonymity and i want poor people
doxxing themselves which
goes back to the lack of nuance when you
have a limited amount of characters and
you're just like throwing out a random
like idea that you know what's going on
in your head
and then people put it out there and a
couple characters and like completely
read a million things into it and then
oh wait you said this but you didn't say
this and i saw you defended this part
it's like it's just a little blip of a
thought yeah and if you
if if there's people out there if they
they're like tim's doubling down on this
and i'm like oh yeah i doubled down when
i insulted the leftists too
but do you think i when i say never
apologize do you think that means i'll
apologize to you
look if you got mad about something i
said i don't know like
sometimes we disagree on stuff but i
will say this anonymity is fantastic and
important that's why we've had a lot of
discussions about an
anonymity versus uh using your real name
i i
obviously know the founding fathers went
under pseudonyms before but it was when
they used their real names and made
those assertions and declared that they
would put their lives their honor
their families on the line that was the
profound move but i will make one very
important point to those on the right
who for one please don't look too deeply
into
what was a passive subtweet for one
thing and uh i i don't apologize for
having opinions
um i think my my point is true that if
i'm gonna have a conversation with
someone hiding behind a wall i don't
know who they are or they're wearing a
mask
like they have certain advantages over
me that's not same level of risk
um but i will mention there are dozens
of stories
there was one story not that long ago
september where a teacher wore a black
lives matter mask at work
refusing to back down from her ideology
and was threatened with losing her job
and she said i refuse and they fired her
there was a man at a taco bell who wore
a black lives matter mask and they said
take it off or else he says
never and then i get people tweeting at
me saying i can't lose my job
and i'm like that's absolutely fine and
i understand that i've stayed on the
show numerous times
i can respect people who have families
and say it's very hard for me to do i
understand it's much much easier for me
because i don't have kids to make a lot
of these moves i've never hid behind
that or claimed it wasn't true
but you need to understand that even
though that is true and i respect it
the advantage the left has is that
they're absolutely willing to sacrifice
themselves for their ideology
and many on the right or the
anti-critical race theorists the ntsjws
and conservatives are less willing to do
it not completely
but i it seems to be uh
at least a tendency at the very least
because these people are willing to go
out and and and perhaps it's interesting
because
they know they they have less risk
simply by by virtue of their theirs
institutional infiltrations but i
believe that their institutional
infiltrations are built upon
the fact that they're willing to not
back down and that gets the media on
their side they get the squeaky wheel
that gets the grease so
there's a big challenge in whether or
not you should stick your name on
everything you say you probably
shouldn't
but there is an important point that i
believe that if every single person who
opposed wokeness
right now at their job said it it would
be over
because the polls show it is a
microscopic fraction that believes these
things
and if every single person said i will
not comply with these policies or i will
file an eeoc complaint
it would be over the challenge is the
left is all about collectivism and
organization and the right is all about
individual liberties less willing to do
it
i think there's this interesting thing
and it's part of one of the
takeaways that i was hoping to to make
in the book the war on small business
about decentralization is i think
there's a way
to be individual and come together
you know collectivism is for the good of
the group
individuals coming together people who
are like-minded
who are using you know their individual
each individual thought
but like they're they're you all coming
together to have a little bit more heft
and so i think there's a different way
to be able to do that and so for
something like wokeness
you know maybe it's that they're all
doing it privately that that you get
a hundred people who pick up the phone
and i'll call the representative
privately so that you've made your point
known but you haven't put it out on
social media
where as we've just talked about you
know segment before
we don't need your that's not your lane
of expertise or it's not your dire you
don't need to be
on everything but if it's something
that's important to you you don't want
to have it broadcast
i think there's a way to do that that's
not necessarily in the public domain
that's still effective
here's one of the challenges uh the left
has institutional power
and many of these younger millennials on
the left have much less to lose but when
they tweet something
like 50 tweets we'll hit a major
corporation saying you're racist for
x they can be pictures of bunnies and
squirrels and communist squirrels and
shake with their avatars but the company
fears the left ideology
and so be even with anonymity in this
regard it could be
one person sending all these messages
the company assumes were under attack
there was a
joke i think it was maybe family guy
they were like we received 70 calls last
night which means 7 billion people are
upset with us
now here's the issue if real people with
real names
who have their phone numbers or their
identification
complained the company does recognize
that we're getting hit by actual bad
reviews
and so this these are tactics that the
right have implemented that have worked
like uh giving one star reviews on apps
and things like that
but that that could be an uh anonymous
as well so i'll put it this way
if 30 communist squirrels and clown
pictures emailed a company
they are scared of the ideology but if
30 anti-woke
real people emailed that has equal power
if you're using an anonymous account and
you're saying i'm right wing or whatever
they disregard it they're not scared of
that
but they are scared of actual people so
you look at what's happening in these
schools
these mothers these fathers they are
standing their
faces shown names out there one guy gets
arrested refusing to back down
they have put these people these loud in
the london county have put their names
on the line to fight for what they
believe in
and it's sending it's having a ripple
effect across the country which is very
effective
so yeah and by the way that's a place
where they should be doing that that's
their kids
that's the thing that they're in charge
of and i think that's the the point
point about picking your battles
and really doubling down in those areas
that you're passionate about
that you have the most expertise that
have you know that you have
the influence i mean those are the
battles that should be fought not every
battle needs to be fought that way
it's tough you know um strategic
retreats make sense
definitely anonymity is super important
because you see like the soviet union i
mean they would root people out and
execute them put them in gulags if they
if they could figure out who they were
so if you got mines is an anonymous
social network which
almost sounds like an anomaly or like um
uh but basically you can you can peer
you can like peer validate who you are
without actually
showing who you are by being like uh i
like dogs i like can i like skittles or
whatever and then they're like yeah
that's ian that's ian that's ian but you
never actually say who you are publicly
that's a form of like anonymous social
networking but tim i'm i'm so down i'm
so into what you're saying
about not what i think is don't argue
with
faceless masses of people don't argue
with people that aren't speaking
with their voice if it's writing on a
wall
and you have to go check on it's just it
is such a waste of time and energy and
it
personally it infuriates me to go
through that and like you said they
don't have the risk
when you're anonymous you don't have the
risk you have to back up what you say
with with who you are
so you can be a lot more ruthless and
like you can say stuff you don't believe
and there's no repercussions
i do love people claiming that i'm a
grifter while i'm simultaneous letting
people attack me saying they won't
support me anymore and there's and i've
become a monster and things like that
it's like
i just okay so i'll apologize that's
very curious to me i love this
so like what is the actual grift like
i'm trying to because i'm into really
into business models and scale a little
bit like
like like what's the grip by angering my
own audience
the left who hates me will continue to
hate me and i'll just lose money
that's a really bad grip let's
let's have a let's have a brainstorming
session a strategic business session i'm
not
i have to uh look if i if i say never
apologize
you know i mean it what i mean by never
apologize is if i genuinely think i did
something wrong i'll apologize so
when i that's how i am too like if i'm
sorry like i'm super sorry and
you're gonna hear about it but it's not
very often i tweeted about andy no
and then like the next day i looked at
the tweet and i was like that was really
crass
like i probably could have articulated
this better twitter sucks and so i said
a couple times like i i probably should
have expressed myself way better i was
frustrated i was having this heated
conversation i see this and i got really
angry but you're a human being you
shouldn't be expected to to like
communicate perfectly at all
points in time like who again who are
you apologizing to
andy okay so you're apologizing to okay
so if it was
it was a question if it was to him i get
it but if it was too like that you know
like people like make apologies to the
twitter verse
like i don't know why you would
apologize to the twitter verse for doing
that i think
apologizing to the person yeah yeah i i
i stand by my opinion on it 100
that you know andy should be leading the
charge and not personally being down in
these groups he should be teaching
people to do these things
i'm not saying it's easy but uh i could
articulate that better so like
like a ninja academy because that's like
a better a better business model well
like
right wing watch but for regular people
who don't like extremists like antifa
you know what i mean or or like the aclu
maybe before they lost their way but
when it comes to like me saying you have
better political discourse with people
who have you know their names and their
and
and everything i mean uh i think that's
just true
and it's not because every single person
who is using an avatar or a fake name or
a username
is a bad person it's because there are a
lot of people trolling and it's because
when i'm looking through
you know my tweets and my my responses
and i i i respond to people every so
often
it's it's it's it's pulling it it's
you're trying to pull a name out of a
hat and hope you're getting the honest
person
out of a group of people who have
communist squirrel accounts that are
just love
that's such a huge thing for me too is
that like
i'll have any discussion except for ones
that are in bad
faith and also on twitter because i just
don't think it's a good forum
but but in terms of like actually like
kind of getting into things like if
you're coming at
something in bad faith like there's just
no point it's hard to know for sure but
we should definitely get to super chats
because i don't want to
um
yeah so so this is people are saying you
know that was kind of the point like oh
you'll read an anonymous super chat but
not
respond to someone on twitter not argue
in text
don't waste your energy arguing in text
if you don't have to good rules yeah and
and
i'm gonna try uh look i'll i'm gonna
write this one right here channel 404
says tim you are truly no better than
the corporate media peddling fear and
despair and drooling at every mention of
war
shame on you oh okay like i'll take all
the criticism and i'll read it
and i'm just saying like i'm not going
to get dragged on twitter by the
communist squirrel anymore you know what
i mean it could be me for all you know
don't don't buy ian's sitting there like
i mean to be fair
the communist squirrel like they don't
have a choice if they stand up against
it
then they're squirrel no more so i mean
i kind of give this comment
the communist squirrel of pass you know
i i absolutely think writing under a
pseudonym and anonymous
publishing like the founding fathers it
is is great i'm not gonna
i mean i mean the actual communist
squirrel like he doesn't want to be a
communist
or a squirrel well maybe yeah no he's
just a cute squirrel
but now the communists have him and so
he can't speak out
they're actually saying they're actually
a communist squirrel account it's really
good
franklin did poor richard zalman are you
guys familiar with poor richard's
yeah for like 40 years he was writing
under a pen name because it was too
dangerous i think to speak up
he was exceeding the anti-british
propaganda for like 30 years
and alice in wonderland was considered
to be like subversive
allegory because you would be in trouble
and i i get all that
uh i'm just saying i am not going to uh
or
i'm going to say i have better i don't
even think i just like science
i just like squirrels that's just at the
end of the day i love them i like
squirrels that's right
i'm just putting it out there guys if
you're a squirrel i like you
all right the civic national says
britain has been the underdog throughout
history many have tried few have
succeeded
let them come our spirit will never
break as you said
thucydides trap brexit was a success
britannia
will return to her former glory god save
the queen the civic nationalist i'm a
big fan i love your your uh
enthusiasm and support for your country
and i i really do love the civic
nationalist
uh super chats about like the difference
in perspective between the american
revolution that we've had this
conversation so i
when we talk about the uk and we're even
a bit dismissive
i i respect your happy fourth of july
absolutely
downey jr says hms defender is part of
the carrier strike group
csg21 which is on tour and heading to
south china sea
give it a google wow boris johnson wants
uk to be the best naval power in eu
again
also russia always entering uk waters
amazing good for him
all right ted two says tim your take on
the crimea exchange sounds a lot like
supporting a modern-day tonkin gulf
incident i implore you to pause reassess
and look into the details further
i don't think your assessment was
accurate um i'm not sure which
specifically about my assessment you're
referring to but i'm not an
advocate for for any war conflict i
we're seeing russia make claims or maybe
it's my assessment that i'm saying um
the uk is saying russia never fired a
warning shot i don't believe the uk in
this regard i think russia
has no reason not to fire a warning shot
like if russia said they fired a warning
shot they could easily just go pow it's
a warning shot you know
and a bbc journalist said they heard
shots fired but the uk says it was a
training drill or something so yeah
justin dube says you should try and get
immortal technique on the show
oh yeah absolutely all right let's see
what we got
liz scars says a special guy in my life
is going through a tough medical ordeal
i would really appreciate lots of
healing wishes for mike jules and
chula it's going to be a long summer but
we're fighting this with you
we love you mike yeah shout out lots of
prayers
tyler klovik says what if the hms
destroyer story is a distraction for the
us conflict where
mcafee didn't kill himself man they got
mad at me for saying
it's so weird the mainstream media is
like how dare you claim that a guy who
said he would never end his own life
ending his own life as a conspiracy
they got mad at me about that i'm like
here's a question i have it i i honestly
don't know the answer to this
are there photos like do we know that
he's actually done no that was my
question did he fake his staff so like
not to like take the conspiracy theory
like what's up but like like is is
do we have a confirmation on this yeah i
don't know i
don't know i mean it's the picture i
mean like i don't know that he's
i mean this is just what's been reported
right all right so we got we got
uh two comments here um beltazed says
i'm a trucker in the northwest there is
a shortage of drivers here have a good
job paying thirty dollars an hour but
switching to tanker because it's two
times current pay
wow and the loan raptor says i work for
the biggest freight company in the south
east and i can confirm that there
is a trucker shortage as well as a
freight handler shortage in our company
too much freight not enough workers wow
yep
it's like right on the verge of
automation uh another comment
saying uh from tim miners i'm a trucker
in california there is a driver shortage
especially in fuel
i'm about to get a job hauling fuel
since it pays six to seven dollars an
hour more than what i make now plus lots
of hours
get that money get that cash i love it
thank you for that for the money
the market is healing oh yes the market
has
said we pay more gas prices are going to
go up
and then everything else is going to go
but again but again remember
that the only reason there was this
shortage is because the government
disrupted the market and created the
situation
to disclose people to begin with so this
is this is not
the market deciding this needed to
happen this is the
uh aft coming out of the after effect of
interference
all right we got uh travel by dice's i
got a weird call from the air force the
other day
they said they were going over old
applications they asked if i was still
interested i applied in 2008. wow that's
strange
all right how do we know it was the air
force and like not one of those like
spam calls
because i'm getting all kinds of weird
stuff too yeah
have you ever get those calls where you
answer it's just a recording of someone
speaking mandarin
no i always get a woman with this really
annoying voice i don't know why they
always have it's like
your warranty is expired it's like do
you really
think that that's gonna get me to call
you back like come on take the pitch
down a little bit lady
all right rowan thor says carol was
absolutely right on so many parts of the
u.s wanting to hire but not being able
to get workers
i just moved to a rural area for a g
work and i am working six days a week
and employers want more
well i i i'll mention too i think we
have a couple uh
we've we've had like a couple thousand
requests for work to work here yeah so i
certainly think that passion is a
driving factor and
that's why i kind of feel like there's
some truth to people want a fulfilling
job
they don't want to just jump back into
the labor market with something they're
going to be unhappy with they want to
take the time to
find something you know which by the way
i want to say this is an important point
is that is capitalism as well the fact
that we have the privilege
there are people across the world who
can barely support themselves let alone
choose how to support
themselves let alone do so by pursuing a
passion the fact that you can make those
choices
the freedom and choice that is
capitalism it's not always about the
dollar things it's about having that
freedom and choice so
so good for people who say you know i'm
not driven just by a dollar
freedom choice i want a passion freedom
of choice all right let's see
where was i where was i at i just lost
the okay bobby bob says what is the best
argument for and against 15
and what would happen if it's passed
okay so i'm assuming that's directed at
me
um i am against any sort of interference
in the market at all and particularly
putting it
on a national basis where you've got you
know every single person
in every age group in every place from
arkansas to new york having the same
thing if you do this
on an artificial basis and you kind of
go up the chain
what's going to end up happening is
you're going to keep more people who are
young
and low skilled out of the workforce
you're going to end up driving up the
cost because it's not just that person
who's waged that unskilled laborer whose
wage is increased
but the person above them then wants an
appropriate increase the person above
them wants the appropriate increase
suppliers and vendors are all dealing
with the same thing you're going to end
up
paying 23 for a slice of pizza or the
place is going to shut down
and the person who's now making 15 an
hour is not going to have any more
spending power and then they're going to
say 25 dollars
right so so you cannot you cannot do
that
let people your work your choice let
people make those decisions we're seeing
it now there's 9.3 million jobs that
need to be filled we don't need to
artificially
continue to increase the wage there is
no good argument that
as thomas ellis said the actual minimum
wage is zero and
if i have a tweet on this if you want to
go um at carol j
s roth the minimum wage the minimum wage
is history i also talk about this in the
book
is is actually keeping immigrants and
women and people of color out of the
workforce like that's the point of it is
to keep people out of the workforce
it has the same effect today all right
so i did see one chat where someone said
that we should have carl benjamin on the
show and
yes any time if anybody has an open
invite it's
of course carl benjamin of benjamin of
the locus eaters podcast and of course
count dankula
but they're across the pond and there's
a bunch of travel restrictions but the
moment they have an opportunity
not only that but i say this of anybody
be it someone on the left or the right
when they host their own show it's hard
to ask someone to stop doing their show
to do my show because it's kind of like
a favor it's not like we pay
people but uh carl man we love you we'd
love to have you on the show whenever
you have any availability
lotus eaters right you said locust or
something like you said
it's on the bread it is it is
no uh joshua ryman says ian i love you
thank you i feel like now instead of
being the devil's advocate you serve a
greater purpose being
yourself keep being you dude we have
opportunity to help a lot of people
and it's just if it's anything but
bringing bringing people to see like
this this this crappy uh
you know don't buy houses manipulation
stuff to
bringing amazing people in to talk about
their expertise tell me tim
i i just need to uh be honest with with
everybody and tell them
the real reason we started this podcast
it was because not enough people knew
about graphene we're about to though and
i have it right here thanks for bringing
it up
are you familiar with it i'm not it's
monolayered carbon
uh hexagonally latticed and it's got
incredible mechanical properties it's
electrically conductive super capacitive
it's like a semiconductor it's gonna
have a 21st century industry
ian ian's talk of graphene got me to
literally invest
i bought stock in a company that
produces graphene because ian wouldn't
stop talking about it and i'm like i was
gonna
so i have stock in it but how's it doing
really well
actually yeah 20 28 29 we're gonna see
mass inflection of graphene
just hearing like uh the next meme stock
is graphene
probably yeah well like you know i i i
agree it's a wonderful material but when
steve bannon's here talking about the
economy and then ian went into like we
need to get
american manufacturing of graphene i
laughed i bust out laughing but steve
bennett was like
yeah like we should be manufacturing new
materials and and becoming the hub for
this
but it was just like it was it was that
it was the greatest moment of the
graffian argument i love him
yeah he's so open-minded all right i'm
gonna i'm gonna read this one
um it's drama e but lmv says hi tim and
team did you see the video the
quartering made saying you had a
meltdown
i watched it he's all over the place
looks like clout chasing to me and maybe
a little grudge over that scheduling
issue a few months ago
i'll be honest um i'm not i i get drama
videos made about me all the time by
like people on the left
there are people on the right i guess
there's like some weird you know
nazi meme about me because i don't know
whatever but it happens all the time
i was just kind of like i it was one
tweet it was like i tweeted
like this like two like it was like a
tweet and then like i did like three
responses to it i don't understand why
that's a meltdown
meltdown or like how it was advocating
people dox themselves
so i just tweeted i tweeted at him like
okay kathy newman
like so so you're saying you know so
you're saying or whatever
and i'm like dude i don't know i didn't
i i
people can make videos about whatever
they want i'm i it's the weirdest thing
to me is people are like tim so
egotistical and arrogant and i'm like i
do
say i am but i'm also willing to accept
that people make fun of me all of the
time they called me a bald [ __ ]
they make videos saying i'm having a
meltdown they're allowed to do it
i respect their right to do it and i'm
an adult and i just say
all right you know but i will say um
it it it brings up an interesting
conversation and i'm just interested to
hear what people think
and you know so whatever yeah so uh
jeremy's allowed to not like me he's
like he's highlighting
uh what basically we've been talking
about that there's the value to
anonymity but there's also
it's hard to communicate through text
with with anonymized sort i mean that's
also very difficult i think
that discussion with you and jeremy
would be a very interesting one to watch
i
am just annoyed that they've devalued
all these things like
meltdown and owned because like every
time i click on something
it just doesn't get the payoff and i
just feel like if you're gonna say
somebody's having a meltdown
or they were owned like it's gotta be
really good like the bar is really high
we're we're in 2021 now here people so
step up your meltdown games okay
i think i uh you know what really bums
me out is um
i was talking to another prominent
personality over this and they were like
look
like you shouldn't get wrapped up in
this you got to stay focused and i'm
like i am you know like i tweeted people
i get into like troll wars and stuff and
people get all worked up about i don't
care
but i will say one of the most
demoralizing things is that there are a
lot of prominent personalities who have
an opportunity
to lead and i get frustrated when they
don't
and people get mad at me because because
like you know in the conversation i had
with bannon i was mentioning like
we're trying to build all this stuff
timcast.com we're trying to hire people
and make journalism happen
and i don't understand why so many other
people don't do the same thing
because i know how much money some of
these people make very prominent
personalities on twitter and on youtube
who are making mentoring opportunities
uplifting opportunities abundance
mentality
help bring empower other people this is
exactly the conversation we've been
having
but they just buy like material things
for themselves and they're allowed to
i'm not dragging people for wanting
stuff i'm just saying
i wish that we had a little bit of the
ideological fervor in regards to
classical liberalism
freedom and even conservatism and like
traditional liberalism
as the leftists have for wokeness like
their zeal and their passion and their
fearlessness and their rage
exists in much smaller quantities in the
anti-establishment anti-woke and
conservative space yeah i'm obsessed i
mean i'm on fire in this realm
i i think this is why decentralizing
social media and like the fetiverse
uh the future of interconnected
decentralized decentralizing the
the economic system with cryptocurrency
decentralizing obviously
business the military small businesses
it's so important and you want to get
people excited about it you know this is
i went to school for acting
this is why because this stuff's boring
as hell but you want to make people
excited about it
yeah coding development and the crazy
thing is like you don't have to forgo
the ferrari to make the investment it's
just delayed gratification because if
you
uplift more people and you're sitting on
top of that then you end up making more
money they end up making more money
and you can buy two ferraris down the
road so this is this isn't like an
either or
choice there's so many opportunities and
it just kills me and
i don't know if people don't have the
conviction to do it i don't know if
people don't have the knowledge
or i don't know if people don't want
other people to know
that the opportunity is available to
everyone that it's an ego thing
say like i'm special i've somehow like
figured out this special sauce and you
can't instead of going like no pretty
much everyone can figure this out
i will say in in jeremy's defense it's
actually
um casey neistat one of the like you
know godfathers of youtube in terms of
vlogging especially
people asked him about clickbait and he
said the reality of youtube
i'm paraphrasing is that either you find
something that will convince people to
click and watch
or you fizzle out and disappear and
youtube doesn't promote you or support
you and then you get no traffic
so he was like it's the it's the
conundrum of youtube you you're you're
upset that you're using certain titles
or saying things certain ways
but then the alternative is just not
existing at all on the platform because
it really is about
drama and catching people's attention
and things like that but i will address
one
non-super chat from mr obvious who said
i don't make enough to buy a fancy
outpost him we aren't all rich through
grifting
and so there's another thing that i
tweeted people say that it's easy for
you to say these things tim
you have all this money and you can do
all these things my response is
i am not i am not only calling out the
established because i
establishment because i am successful i
am successful because i'm calling out
the establishment yeah dude
i i got i had a contract with i'm going
to publicly state this it was on the
member's only thing but i'll publicly
state this right now because it's been a
long time
i was given a check for 200 000 just
about by
abc news univision as a sign-on bonus
though we want you to start the company
here and we will
here's the check literally that day i
was staring at it
and they said sign up with us and they
gave me 250 000
a year salary plus a massive budget
which account amounted for two millions
of dollars in terms of being able to
produce and do all these things
and i tried breaking that contract and
walking away from it
so people say like it's easy for you to
say timmy all this money
but my whole life like even when i was
broke and homeless i filed a lawsuit
against a company i worked for for
violations of law labor laws and things
like that
and that made me unemployed for months
unable to move because of ongoing
litigation and
on and off homeless so what i mean to
say is
if you're unwilling to take risks i'm
not saying you have to
but no risk no reward for someone like
me it's not the fact that i'm successful
that gives me that
opportunity to do it it's that by by
refusing to bend the knee to abc and all
the money they offered me
and i've told the story about one day i
wake up and they give me an extra 40 000
just boom in my bank account play ball
that's what it felt like they were
saying to me
and i still said no and then i leave and
i start my own
thing and my obstinance and a bit my
arrogance
and my unwillingness to bend the knee to
these corporations
leads me down that path of constantly
building and fighting and doing what i
believe in
i understand not everybody can do that
and i understand a lot of people think
it's arrogant and egotistical
of me and i'm bragging and all that
stuff i don't know how else to say it my
point to most people is if you believe
in yourself and you take the risks you
very well may fail
or you very well may find that on the
other side of the fire is freedom
let me just ask you this do you believe
other people could
do the same thing i believe everyone
could there you go and that's the point
is that anybody if you want it risk and
reward like you said
if you want to to take the risk you have
that opportunity
and you may not everybody may succeed
but you'll have
that potential to succeed and and having
the abundance mentality
lifts all the boats skydiving it's
really scary to take that leap
out of that plane yeah i don't do that
and they they make people go tandem
first right
and people do die skydiving i know a guy
that did rock climbing
it's very very scary to be you know 500
feet up with these you know the
spikes securing your position and a lot
of people do it and some people fall
and then there are these people and this
is the craziest to me you see these
videos of these russian guys who are
like standing on the edge of
a hundred story building like you know
and then they hang from one arm and
they're laughing
i don't know what the reward is for that
yeah i'm not sure it's all risk
said i'm a risk-adjusted return kind of
gal none of those things are produced in
the return for me if they do for you
god bless you but that's where that risk
personal risk reward uh
evaluation has to come into play so i
just uh um
you know my view is when you take a risk
and you throw yourself out there and you
challenge the system
is it is very possible that you end up
you know
living in a van down by the river or
maybe you don't even have a van
but i suppose if you're if you're not
willing to take those risks i will
you know what i'll do i'll do a star
trek reference oh i love the next
generation by the way we always start
your reference here
picard uh has a fake heart captain
picard in that generation he has a fake
heart because he got stabbed in the back
because he got into a bar fight
and he wishes he didn't do it he was so
impertinent in his youth
and so q this powerful omnipotent entity
sends him back in time to change his
circumstances and picard decides
to use his opportunity to stop the fight
and save his heart
and then when he returns to the future
he he's no longer
a captain he is a low-ranking lieutenant
science officer
and when he goes to commander riker and
says do you think i have what it takes
to be in command
riker says let me be honest with you mr
picard you have
never stuck your neck out or taken the
risks required to show the initiative
to be in command so no it is not
realistic and then picard says enough
cue you've made your point
that impertinence in his youth and that
that arrogance and that risk-taking led
him to be one of the greatest captains
of all time in star trek history
there you go star trek i love that i
also just say you know over the course
of my career when people say
what is sort of the number one thing
that you would tell yourself
in terms of going back in time advice to
stuff and it is take
more risk especially when you're young
and you don't have things to lose
like you don't realize like it takes
almost the same effort
to think small as it does to think big
the the economist says jeremy said
several times he respects and likes you
and your grind also going bald young
means you have high testosterone breaks
my mind with stelter
um look like i like jeremy
i think his videos are great i think he
covers good topics
i like his opinions and we disagree on
things
and when i tweeted him calling him kathy
i'm laughing and i'm
i'm i'm hope it's frustrating him
getting trolled
and uh i hope he assumes i'm laughing
too
i think jeremy will end up back on the
show and i think so long
i'm i just think it's funny i think we
all have thicker skin on like whatever
this side is of the culture war
and uh i just find it fun and funny and
and these are these are good ideas to
work out and good arguments to have so
jeremy's always welcome back
um we had a scheduling issue that
happened last time it was really
frustrating for me and
you know uh i apologize to
to jeremy over all you know everything
that happened these things happen
but uh i got no beef i think jeremy's
great i'm i'm glad he's willing to to
smack talk absolutely because if the
right was full of people who were
unwilling to to be mean to each other
and they couldn't be adults about it
move on
it would be as bad as the left you know
what i mean he's smart too i like
that's what's nice about his trolling is
it's perceptive i love you jeremy
all right let's let's see uh let's we'll
just do one we've gone a bit long
um phoebe manser says thank you carol
for validating every reason i based
developing my new business
shop everytown.com thanks to tim and
team okay
so what so is that shopeverytown.com
shop everytown.com i'm going to check it
out thank you
my friends thank you all so much for
hanging out for super chatting for
smashing that like button and being
members at timcast.com sign up there's
gonna be a bonus segment coming up
should be up around 11 or so p.m
you can follow us on facebook and
instagram i know i know facebook
but we're hoping to leverage that
network to guide people to timcast.com
so we're on facebook and instagram at
tim cast irl
by sharing our videos it just it's the
marketing power
it's how we compete with the
establishment and uh works really really
well for the daily wire and ben shapiro
and they're growing like crazy and i'm
happy to hear it
you can also follow me personally at tim
cast and give us a good review and all
that stuff teamcast.com like button
you want to shout anything out perhaps a
book your social media all right so
i've been promoting myself this whole
time so i'm gonna let you promote the
book
the war on small business how the
government used the pandemic
to crush the backbone of america by
carol roth a new york times best-selling
author
i strongly suggest you read this because
one of the biggest
uh subjects on this show is how we saw
the largest transfer of wealth from the
working class
to the oligarchs and we need to
understand how it's happening
why it's happening what they're doing
and knowledge is power my friends if
we're going to combat this
centralization of power and
authoritarianism you need to read books
like this
get it to number one on amazon and what
was the other website you mentioned
and bookshop.org bookshopbookshop.org
so that way other people will see it
other people will read it and they'll
share it with their friends and these
ideas will prevail yes and
i'm also on twitter at carol j s roth as
i tell people i'm sort of a luxury brand
i'm well curated kind of popular but
definitely not for everyone oh i like
how you put that
thanks for coming man and thank you so
much for investigating this and writing
this thank you
uh you guys can follow me at ian
crossland.net and at ian crossland along
all lines of social media you can also
follow the show on minds which i want to
shout out a little bit more because i
love that
decentralized uh aspect of social media
that mines has been working on with the
nomad system and other
other things and follow me there as well
thanks all right and
you guys i've really been thinking about
the topic of grifting because we see it
thrown around so much
and i came up with a definition because
i love my definitions the definition of
grifting is something done in bad faith
for money or clout
and as far as you as far as i can tell
based on everything i know about tim and
our company here that is the antithesis
of what we do
you guys are welcome to follow me at
sourpatchlids on twitter as i try to get
more followers and sour patch kids
you know i'll add one last thing there
are a lot of people who for some reason
it's the weirdest thing to me
there have been some leftists who
haven't made it to this show but wanted
to but then canceled
and there are people saying like tim is
scared to have left us on the show we're
we're we're organizing uh
to have vosh on the show i really
enjoyed the the conversation in the
debate
uh we have we have two other leftists
who i won't have on the show and people
in the chat are mentioning mr obvious
and i guess some people are are saying
that like i'm angry about
his comments or he's trolled me or
something like that no i gotta believe i
i i don't know uh his circumstances but
we would absolutely have
we'll look into it because uh some
people have mentioned anonymity so if
that's not possible it's not possible
but people are like have him on the show
it's like
all right well mr obvious send us an
email uh
send me an email send what spin the ufo
you you so checking that one yep and
then we'll try and figure out what's up
and then for everybody else we will see
you over at timcast.com for the bonus
segment thanks for hanging out bye guys
you